bin eine
ähnliche
U
So, auf geht's!
Ist das noch der alte Emote-Champ?
Ja, korrekt!
Das ist noch der alte Emote-Champ!
Das sieht man daran, dass der alte Emote-Champ...
Ähm, wo hab ich das Bild?
Moment, wo ist mein Klo-Emote?
Ist das viel zu schnell abgespielt wird?
Der neue Emote-Champ hat das Problem nicht!
Das ist Hyper-Shit!
Was meinst du?
Die Switch OLED ist so enttäuschend, weil nicht genügend Chips für das richtige Upgrade
vorhanden sind.
Was genau ist da jetzt...
Also, ich bin mir jetzt nicht ganz sicher, worauf du abziehst.
Ob ich das Display, also ob ich die Idee von der Switch mit einem neuen Display doof finde
oder ob es eine gute Idee wäre, eine stärkere Switch herzustellen.
Ich kann ja mal zu beiden was sagen.
Diesmal ein Discord-Bot geworden, exzellent, exzellent.
Was zur Switch?
Ich hab das nur am Rande heute mitverfolgt, dass sie eine OLED-Switch angekündigt haben.
Ich hab das nicht geguckt.
Also, eine Switch mit einem besseren Display, warum nicht?
Finde ich okay, kann man machen.
Gerade nach dem, mir unerklärlicherweise, aber es gibt trotzdem viele, die das mobil
verwenden, da ist ein gutes Display.
Warum nicht?
Da hab ich keine Schmerzen mit.
Was ich keine gute Idee finde persönlich, kann man sich darüber streiten, aber was
wie gesagt, was ich keine gute Idee finde ist, eine bessere Switch zu bauen oder eine
schnellere Switch zu bauen, wozu führt das, das hat man bei der letzten Konsolengeneration
gesehen, sowohl bei der Xbox, äh, wie hieß die letzte?
Xbox, wie hieß die letzte Xbox One die Xbox One 2.0?
Wie hieß die denn noch einmal?
Xbox One X, Alter, Microsoft-Benahmung, meine Güte.
Dreizehn Dankeschön, zwölf Monate Hyper-Subscription.
Und PS4 Pro, da hast du das gesehen, dass das das Problem war, dass viele Spiele standardmäßig
nicht gut liefen auf der normalen Hardware.
Dadurch, also umgedreht, viele Spiele liefen ganz okay auf der neuen Hardware und ganz
kontenschlecht auf der alten Hardware, sprich man hat dafür gesorgt, dass die eigentliche
Garantie, die es gibt, ich weiß, dass die nicht schneller ist.
Ich beantworte die zwei Teile.
Ich wusste nicht so genau, was er wissen will.
Was wollte ich jetzt sagen?
Also man hat quasi mit dem letzten Konsolenupdate so die Garantie fallen lassen, dass wenn man
sich eine Konsole kauft, die Konsole für die Lebenszeit dieser Konsolengeneration eigentlich
die Spiele in der vom Hersteller geplanten Qualität spielen kann.
Das fand ich schlecht.
So und die Switch braucht überhaupt kein Upgrade.
Das ist ja das nächste.
Nintendo muss einfach nur ihre Spiele ordentlich programmieren oder mal Leute einstellen, die
das können.
Weil man darf nicht vergessen, die Spiele auf der Wii oder auf dem Gamecube oder nimm dir
eine x-beliebige andere Konsole, nimm eine Xbox 360.
Die dürfte auch nicht so um nicht wirklich viel langsamer als eine Switch sein oder nimm
eine Xbox 360.
Die Spiele liefen da ja auch gut drauf.
Also es ist jetzt ja nicht so als ist es ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit, Spiele auch auf schwächere
Hardware ordentlich laufen zu lassen.
Das muss Nintendo machen.
Das heißt, Nintendo brauchen Leute, die ordentlich programmieren bzw. ordentlich optimieren können
und das braucht halt Zeit.
Und wenn Nintendo sagt, hey, wir haben kein Bock mehr noch ein halbes Jahr zu warten und
releasen das lieber früher ohne Optimierung, dann laufen Spiele halt so geil wie, äh,
wie heißt das auf Englisch das Ding?
Buckel.
Da gibt es schöne Videos dazu.
Ja, wie heißt denn dieses Game auf Englisch?
Äh, ja, Age of Keller, das ist es, das ist es.
Ähm, laggy.
Frame rate issues, frame rate.
Wo haben wir hier?
Moment, YouTube.
Weiß nicht ob man das hier schön sieht.
Guckt euch das an, guckt euch das an.
Alter.
Nintendo, please.
Was sind das, 5 FPS?
Man erkennt es ja überhaupt nicht.
So, und das ist was, was weder an der Switch noch an der Switch Pro liegt.
Das liegt daran, weil die Typen nicht in der Lage sind, das ordentlich zu programmieren.
Da kann, da würde eine Switch Pro was bringen.
In dem Fall, sag mal so, da würde vielleicht eine Switch Pro was bringen, wenn man das
Game eins zu eins nimmt und hat eine Switch, die ein bisschen höher getaktet ist, dann
ist halt das Problem vielleicht minimal, minimal weg.
Oder minimal weniger an manchen Stellen.
Mit den harten Frame Drops, das wird eher ein Problem sein, dass du auch mit der Switch
Pro wahrscheinlich nicht behoben kriegst.
Also spürbar ist.
Die müssen den Kram ordentlich optimieren.
Das ist alles.
Dass das, dass das geht, sieht man ja.
Guckt mal Leute.
Es gab Spiele, die sind auf dem 3DS gelaufen.
Wisst ihr, der 3DS, das ist ein besserer Taschenrechner aus heutiger Sicht.
Von dem, was da drin ist.
Wisst ihr was, nicht der 3DS.
Sorry, ich meine nicht den 3DS.
Ich meine den Nintendo DS, nicht den 3DS.
RolloW, danke schön für den Zap.
Ich meine den normalen DS.
Wisst ihr was im Nintendo DS für Hardware drin war?
Das ist, mal ernsthaft.
Das Nintendo DS mit dem, mit einem Handy zu vergleichen ist schon wirklich
Gotteslästerung dem Handy gegenüber.
So ein Nintendo DS hatte im Endeffekt nichts an Hardware.
Das war absolut die langsamste Hardware, die man sich aus heutiger Sicht so vorstellen
kann für so eine Konsole.
Arm CPU.
Hier.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das Ding hatte, das Ding hatte 7, 67 Mhz Arm CPU und so einen I.O.
Prozessor mit 33 Mhz.
Der DS, das ist, jedes Smartwatch ist schneller heute.
Denn ESP 32 ist schneller.
Also das ist wirklich nicht gut.
Darauf hat es so Sachen wie Phantom Hourglass, was ziemlich gut aussah auf dem DS.
Und die Games liefen komplett flüssig.
Ich meine die waren jetzt nicht schön oder so im Vergleich zu heute, aber die liefen flüssig.
Also da sieht man, das ist alles eine Frage.
Das Programmieren und das Optimieren und das man fähige Leute hat.
Ja.
Und außerdem ihr wisst ja, IF und Schleifen sind generell bloated.
Wir verwenden ab jetzt bloß noch Inline Assembler mit Jump.
So, habe ich irgendwas übers Sehen.
RolloW, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Nee, ich glaube, das ist nicht direkt von Nintendo.
Das ist.
Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher.
Okay.
Genau, das ist diese Dynasty Warrior Crossover Geschichte.
Wer auch immer das ist, keine Ahnung, es ist aber nicht direkt von Nintendo.
Allerdings heißt es ja nichts.
Auch die können ordentlich programmieren.
Gerade nachdem das Switch unten drunter mehr oder weniger das ist, was ein Android Handy auch ist.
Also was in den meisten Android Handys auch drin ist.
Nein, das stimmt nicht.
Was in einigen Android Handys drin ist.
Ich muss mal kurz meinen Ad-Set rausziehen.
Und auf der einen Seite mehr als auf der anderen.
So, ich glaube, jetzt besser.
Ja, okay, exzellent.
Ja, das Shield TV, das Shield TV ist ungefähr Nintendo Switch.
Das weiß ich nicht, was da drin ist, aber das Ding klingt alt.
Also wahrscheinlich nicht.
Was ist da drin?
Zeig mal.
CPU.
Steht da irgendwo, steht da irgendwo, was irgendwo, was da drin ist?
Ein, ein was?
Ein Super H3.
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube nicht, dass der schneller ist als der DS.
Ja, aber wie gesagt, also der Nintendo DS hatte nur wirklich schlechte Hardware oder lame Hardware aus heutiger Sicht.
Die Spiele auch gut und flüssig drauf, also ja, das ist Nintendo halt.
Die kriegen es da nicht gebacken.
Moin.
Was gibt es für Taschenrechner?
Du glaubst nicht.
Es gibt sogar Taschenrechner, da läuft Doom drauf.
Wenn sogar schon die Games da ein Video drüber gemacht hätte, dann weißt du, was Sache ist, oder?
Ich will euch eigentlich nur das Game zeigen.
Doom Calculator.
Ja, genau hier, so sieht es dann aus.
Ja.
Aber es läuft, es läuft.
Und das sind richtig, das sind die richtig Oldschool-Dinger, die Texas Instruments-Dinger.
Aber irgendwie, irgendwas mit meinem Headset.
Test, Test, Test. Ach gut, ihr hört das nicht.
Ja, ich bin.
Das liegt aber hier an mir.
Ich bin auf der rechten Seite leiser als auf der linken.
Übrigens, habt ihr die mit Audacity mitgekriegt?
Die Geschichte, genau hier, sind wir schon Spyware.
Also was die gemacht haben ist folgendes, die wurden gekauft, die wurden aufgekauft von irgendeiner Firma.
Und jetzt haben sie ihre Benutzerpolicy geändert.
Und da stehen dann unter anderem so Sachen drin, wie dass sie Crashreports sammeln, das ist nicht schlimm.
Und dass sie Daten sammeln, um mit Law Enforcement, also mit der Polizei zusammen zu arbeiten.
Ok, das ist natürlich typischer CT-Artikel, wo nichts drin steht.
Ja.
Und jetzt gibt es, es gibt auch schon den ersten Fork.
Und schon den ersten Fork auf GitHub, wo die Leute, wo die Leute gerade wieder rausgepatcht haben.
Ich habe übrigens noch eine ura ura uralt Audacity-Version, die hat das Problem nicht.
Guck mal, ich habe 2.2, die ist von 2000.
Keine Ahnung, 2017 oder so.
Ah ja.
Also, dann fangen wir mal an würde ich sagen.
Was wir uns heute angucken ist folgendes.
Windows 11 Insider Review.
Insider Programm, gibt es da auch schon eine ISO von?
Ok, Netzwelt, erzähl uns wie es funktioniert, Alter.
Was ich gelesen habe ist, man muss Windows 10 installieren und dann ein Upgrade-Tool drauf laufen lassen.
Aber das kann ich mir eigentlich nicht vorstellen, dass das das einzige, die einzige Möglichkeit ist.
Meet, ach hier, das ist ja.
Genauso sehen die Windows 10 Insider, die Windows 11 Insider aus.
Ja, Vater, Mutter, zwei Kinder mit dem Surface oder was das ist, sind hier am gucken.
Keine Ahnung.
Also, zeig mal her.
Windows 11 runterladen, so installiert ihr die Review-Version, dann zeig ich her.
Nee, der Heise-Download erbringt dich auch nur auf die Windows-Seite.
Die Monkertos ist die ISO.
Heise, guck mal, hättest du das ausprobiert, dann wäre es dir auch aufgefallen, dass wenn du Heise durchklickst,
das habe ich nämlich vorhin schon mal gemacht, dass man einfach nur das Insider Programm.
Ok, jetzt anmelden, machen wir es.
Wir melden uns an, alles gut.
Ach so, fuck.
Fake-Account-Time.
Fake-Account, ja, Google, Google ist gut.
Fake-Account-Time, jawoll.
Create a new one.
Yes, das ist die Best-Email-Adresse überhaupt.
Next.
Passwort.
Ok, Moment.
Ich muss mir gerade mal den Passwort im zweiten Bildschirm ausdenken.
Das muss jetzt Bigframe-Password-Time, Leute.
Massive.
Ok, alles klar.
Ich brauch das nur für den Stream heute, ansonsten kann man es gleich wieder rückgängig machen dann.
Wie, warum muss man das Passwort nicht bestätigen?
Was ist denn jetzt, wenn ich mich vertippt hab?
Great-Account-Birthday-1990. Ich hätte mich nennen sollen, Cute-Weep-1990.
Auf, gib her. Auf Microsoft.
Sagt bloß, die haben das geplockt. Das wäre ein ganz schöner Sack.
Ich muss mir jetzt einen Fake-Account machen.
Aber normalerweise plockt Microsoft das nicht.
Die wollen im nächsten Report schreiben, wir haben 500.000. Ah, da ist es doch, da ist es doch.
Excellent. Verify your email. Aha.
Nein, nein, nein, keine Tipps.
Hoffentlich keine Telefonnummer.
Was? Please solve puzzles so we know you are not a robot. Ok, next.
Tap the arrows.
Was zum Teufel ist das?
Was sehe ich da überhaupt?
Soll es ein Kessel sein oder was?
Ah, ok. Jaja, jetzt erkenne ich es.
Gut, 35, 25 Sekunden, Punkt.
Also es war, es ist im ersten Blick echt nicht zu erkennen, oder?
So, wir sind eingeloggt, Massive.
Jaja, ich stimme zu, ich stimme alles, kein Problem, ich stimme bei allem zu.
Mit dem was? Mit dem Flyting?
Ja, gib mir ein ISO.
Gib mir ein ISO. Ja, wie?
Sign in.
Nochmal.
Ok, ich sign mich auch nochmal hin, kein Problem.
Ich kann mir die ISO auch gleich dann von eurer Seite runterladen, aber das muss doch möglich sein.
Keep me signed in, jawoll.
Ja, ok.
Wo zum? Selected Edition, hier haben wir es doch, Def.
Das alle neu, Windows 10?
Wait a minute.
Wo ist Windows 11?
Ist das das vielleicht?
Wait a minute.
Ja, was ist es denn jetzt?
Ja, Windows 10, alles klar.
Ich will es doch einfach nur downloaden, Leute, please.
Checkt das irgendjemand?
Ok, Bild was? 21354.
Nee.
Windows 11.
Ok, wie kriege ich einen fucking Windows 11?
Auf der Insider-Page, ich bin doch auf der Insider, besuchen Sie Inside Windows 11, bin ich doch schon.
Alter, Microsoft, kann das jetzt, warum ist das so schwer?
Ich will das offiziell runterladen, das kann doch nicht so schwer sein, wo ist das auf der Seite?
Ich glaube, ich bin da zu dumm für.
Download.
Das geht doch, gibt es da echt keinen ISO?
Ach, da gibt es echt keinen ISO?
Ok.
Na gut.
Macht doch schnell das Windows 11 VM.
So, dann lade ich das von euch runter.
Ach, Moment, das hatten wir doch das letzte Mal auch schon mal dieses Tool hier, ne?
Das kenne ich noch, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das kommt mir bekannt vor.
Select.
Insider-Version, Windows 11, Insider-Bild, ARM X64, genau.
Arabisch würde ich sagen, oder?
Waller.
Ich würde sagen, wir installieren das auf Englisch.
So, Professional.
Ähm, das muss ich über Linux machen.
Ok, big brain time, big brain time, das ist nicht so einfach, einen ISO runterzuladen.
Hast du noch genug Platz für eine Windows 11 VM? Ja, kein Problem.
Ich habe Windows 11 schon laufen hier im Hintergrund, die kann ich einfach überbügeln.
Ok, was?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich hier runter lade, aber ich mache das mal lieber mit Linux.
Wer weiß, wer weiß, was da Sache ist.
Ok, was habe ich hier runter geladen?
Ah ja, ok.
Ist das, ist das Batch, Batch-Script oder sowas? Meine Güte, gibt es das nicht, gibt es das nicht auch für normale Benutzer?
Tja, da ist es doch, ne.
ISO, ist da kein ISO?
Was zum Geier, warum ist das so kompliziert? Ok, dann machen wir das jetzt hier drüber.
Wo ist, auf Deutsch auch noch, ne ISO Englisch.
Die, die mit natürlich äußerst, äußerst vertrauenswürdigen Quellen.
Was ist das, warum geht denn das hier nicht?
Warum geht denn das hier nicht? Das haben wir doch schon mal ausprobiert.
Windows, Insider-Version, x64,
Windows Professional.
Was ist denn Windows, was ist denn P, P, P Pro?
Das fuckt mich für richtig aber um jetzt.
Download ISO-Compiler in OneClick.
Run CMD-File.
Nein, nein, ich will einfach Update OS in OneClick.
Was, gibt es das nicht für Linux?
Oh komm mal, hier gibt es noch mehr, hier gibt es noch mehr.
Ich hab legit keine Ahnung, was mir die Leute hier posten, sowas da.
Oh, das ist, das sieht advanced aus.
Was kann man hier machen? Nicht, dass da jetzt irgendwelche Porn-Seiten oder so kommen.
Okay, latest public build, Windows 11.
Windows 11, Insider,
Insider,
AMD 64.
Genau, das will ich haben.
Choose language.
Ach so, hier.
Next.
Ich will, ich will Pro.
Download and convert to ISO.
Das ist krass kompliziert gemacht.
Ach guck mal, das gibt es sogar für Linux hier, beste, beste.
Okay, excellent, excellent.
Hatte das jetzt markiert?
Pro usability, die Seite.
Was mache ich denn hier überhaupt?
Zip?
Was?
Okay.
Was auch immer.
Ich hätte es nicht gedacht, dass es so kompliziert ist, an Windows ISO zu kommen.
Aber anscheinend, was so, des Access?
Ah, hier, hier.
Linux, Linux, okay, okay.
Ah ja, sehr, sehr interessant.
Das soll ich jetzt ausführen, oder wie?
Okay, ich, Leute, Leute, wir sind in AVM.
Was soll schon schief gehen?
Was, was, was kann denn schon passieren?
Was genau passiert da jetzt was?
Was, was bin ich hier sehend?
Okay, nebenbei können wir den anderen Kram runterladen, den hier einer gepostet hat.
Aus so, so, so wirklich hoch vertrauenswürdigen Quellen wie von High Drive.
Wird das hier andere?
High Drive.
Kriegt man auf High Drive Porn angezeigt, wenn man da drauf geht?
Sack.
Das muss ich mir jetzt erstmal, erstmal checken.
Nee, nee, nee.
Moment, High Drive, war das nicht Strato?
War das nicht Strato?
Stream kaputt?
Nee, Stream ist nicht kaputt.
Zu viel, zu viel Download, zu viel Download.
Auf einmal.
Ich check den Unterschied nicht.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen Windows 11 ISO Englisch und der Urversion?
Wie nennt ihr jetzt die Urversion?
Professional, High Drive.
Unable to display, okay, Download.
Cobalt.
Warum, warum, warum cobalt.de?
Und gibt's nicht auf Englisch?
Kann nicht, das hier.
Super Multi, was zum Geier?
Downloade ich da überhaupt?
Oh guck mal hier, mein ISO ist am Entstehen schon.
Mein ISO isot vor sich hin.
Was auch immer der da macht im Hintergrund.
Aber hauptsache 100% CPU Last.
Urversion ohne sämtliche Updates danach.
Ist das nicht bei der ISO normal?
Erstmal den Bitcoin meiner einbauen.
Das scheinen mir höchst seriöse Quellen zu sein, wo ich den Kram herkriege.
Was ist denn der offizielle, was ist denn die offizielle Variante, um Windows 11 zu bekommen?
Windows 10 Upcranen, oder?
Hier haben wir doch ein Windows 10, ne was ist das?
Das ist die Windows 11 VM, was hatten wir denn hier drauf?
Wir sind doch hier, hier haben wir doch schon Insider, hier haben wir doch schon mal Insider gemacht, oder?
Aber das Update, das Upcrate dauert wahrscheinlich wieder drei Stunden, das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Sind wir hier nicht Windows, Windows Insider?
Warte mal, was war denn das nochmal für eine VM?
Handy? Ach ne, das war da, wo wir WinGet ausprobiert haben.
Sind wir hier Insider gewesen schon?
Wie sieht man denn, ob man Insider ist?
Wie der Song heißt, das ist...
Ripple Field aus Kirby's Dream Land 3.
Sind wir schon Insider? Takt mal her.
Ne wir sind kein Insider.
Wo, wie wird man denn Insider? Ich vergesse das jedes Mal, ich mache das zu selten.
Bei Updates habe ich doch hier.
Update.
Insider.
Hier.
Diagnostics, okay.
Nee, haben wir nicht gesagt, man muss, dann aktiviert das, aktiviert das, wenn wir Windows 10 haben.
Dann, dann wird das nicht, dann wird das nichts.
Dann, dann nehmen wir einfach das, was ich hier gerade runter lade, ist doch okay.
Guck mal, gleich ist mein ISO fertig, gleich ist mein ISO fertig.
Ja ja, aber das Insider Programm alleine bringt doch nichts.
Die haben doch geschrieben, man braucht ein aktiviertes Windows 10, dass das überhaupt funktioniert.
Und ich habe kein aktiviertes Windows 10.
Nope Champ.
Wart bis mein ISO fertig ist, geht doch schnell, guck mal, so gleich durch.
Ja ja, aber Insider allein bringt nichts.
Also so wie ich das gelesen habe, musst du ein aktiviertes Windows 10 haben.
Dann joins du Insider.
Und dann kannst du das mit irgendeinem Tool upgraden.
Was gibt es bei Windows 11 so Neues?
Tja, den mittleren Startbutton.
Und undockbare Fenster.
Und Zeug, was wir uns jetzt gleich angucken.
Man braucht kein.
Hat das jemand schon ausgebildet, man braucht kein aktiviertes Windows 10.
Viel Windows im Stream, ja das stimmt.
Kann man nicht drumherum.
Manchmal, manchmal muss man dadurch Emotionen sind neu.
Ja, also die Präsentation war echt schon ganz schöner Fail.
Am schlimmsten fand ich, wo die eine erzählt hat, dass sie früher immer mit ihrem Vater
Windows Spiele gespielt hat.
Das war ganz furchtbar emotional für sie.
Something went wrong.
This won't take long.
Okay, okay.
Die E-Mail Adresse brauche ich.
Beste Microsoft account.
Jawoll.
Komm her.
Next.
Mein super Insider account hier.
Enter Passwort.
Das.
Sign in.
Naja, Next.
This won't take long.
Na dann gucken wir mal.
Was?
Def Channel gehe ich mal von aus.
Confirm.
Restart.
Perfekt.
Auf geht's.
Was?
Def Channel ist Windows 11?
Ne, so wie ich das verstanden habe, musst du jetzt erst noch irgendeinen Upgrade Tool
ausführen.
Mal gucken, mal gucken.
Wir machen jetzt, wir machen gerade alles parallel.
Guck mal, wir haben den Windows 10 ISO jetzt.
Richtig Big Brain.
Wir haben einen ISO.
Und wir haben hier noch einen ISO runtergeladen.
Also mehr, mehr Sachen können wir jetzt eigentlich nicht haben.
Wir haben jetzt, wir haben jetzt eins, zwei, zwei ISOs.
Restart.
Und jetzt?
Ne, brauchst nicht nach Deutschland einfach Updates suchen.
Achja, echt?
Porgerz.
So, wir haben auf jeden Fall genug RAM, genug Disk, genug CPUs.
Das ist aber, das Windows Logo sieht noch okay aus.
Das kann es doch nicht sein.
Was hat dir eigentlich geritten dieses neue Windows Logo so hässlich zu machen?
Ich meine nicht so, dass Windows Logos jetzt immer schon wahnsinnig Big Brain waren.
Aber warum muss das Windows Logo jetzt so überhaupt nicht mal nach Windows aussehen?
Naja, nervt nicht.
Was hatten wir hier eigentlich?
Was ist denn das hier nochmal gewesen?
What the fuck?
Ach, das war dieses, dieses komische Kui, ne?
Hacker Man, Hacker Man.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Ich muss neu starten.
What the fuck?
What is, what is happening?
Ich will nicht wieder gededost werden wegen meiner IP.
Ich starte jetzt neu.
Das Ding liegt immer direkt bei meiner IP.
Das ist so, als ich auch vom Letzten war.
Dann sind wieder irgendwelche Dedos Leute am Start.
Das muss nicht sein.
Das hatten wir jetzt schon oft genug.
Ilal Kalf, Dankeschön, 8 Monate Sub.
Wobei die Dedos Leute sind eigentlich immer nur am Start, wenn ich irgendwelche Webseiten,
Dinggeschichten oder sowas mache.
Oder VM Server in der Cloud oder sowas.
Da kommen die Dedos Leute immer.
Ok, Update.
Ich muss diesen Krempel mal kurz hier entfernen.
Uninstall.
Ok, Hallo, Windows Update, please.
Nerv nicht rum, OneDrive.
Zu OneDrive kann ich nur sagen.
Piss dich also.
Leak, Pinterest, Orchat, seid ihr schon eingeloggt?
Corelog, Dankeschön für den Sub.
So.
Und jetzt?
Windows Update.
Alle Updates machen, danach Windows 11 Update verfügbar.
Ok, dann mach mal Windows.
Let's go.
Wir machen jetzt.
Denkst du manchmal, ob einer es ernst meint, wenn der Hacker mehr in dem Chat schreibt?
Nee.
Gut, wenn es jetzt nicht gleich anfängt, mache ich eine zweite VM und installiere mit der ISO.
Wir haben ja alles, wir haben ja alles.
Wir haben die ISO, wir haben die Möglichkeit, das zu upgraden.
Ich habe übrigens heute die Nachricht gekriegt auf der Arbeit,
dass wir mindestens 40 ganz furchtbar fette Hardware Server außer Betrieb nehmen.
Und da habe ich mir so gedacht, wäre es jetzt nicht eine gute Zeit,
mal ein bisschen Krypto-Mining zu betreiben, aber das wollen sie alle nicht.
Weil ich muss den Strom nicht bezahlen, ich muss die Hardware nicht bezahlen.
Was spricht denn dagegen, solange alle zustimmen?
Aber nee, keiner will, keiner will.
Haben wir es bald, Windows.
Hast du TPM in VNW hinzugefügt?
Nö, muss man das machen?
Zeyda Teddy, Hochmut881.
Und irgendeine habe ich noch vergessen, aber Dankeschön für die Subs.
Nee, ich glaube, ich habe keinen vergessen.
Eine Umfragenvorschlag erhalten.
Wo ist er?
Ach da, Hotdogs oder alles andere?
Ist das eine gute Umfrage?
Also ich würde sagen, Hotdogs sind okay,
aber andere Sachen sind mir lieber.
Wir machen das jetzt doppelt.
Also wir machen das jetzt mehr kleisig.
Hast du was verpasst?
Nee, nee, wir installieren noch.
Download.
Ich brauche mal ein ISO.
Exzellent.
Wir machen jetzt einfach noch eine VM und installieren da vom ISO.
Weil, weil, warum sollten wir den Kram jetzt doppelt laufen lassen?
Guck mal hier, der ist schon wieder, der.
Der braucht schon wieder fünf Stunden.
Wir machen jetzt einfach das hier.
Das kann ich jetzt hier nämlich einfach überschreiben mit dem ISO,
weil das ist mein eigentliches.
Sag mal, das probieren wir jetzt noch mal schnell aus.
Update sich Windows 11 auf Windows 11.
Das hier ist dieses Windows 11 Preview, was wir mal installiert haben.
Kann man das auf die aktuelle Dev-Version installieren?
Oder hat da Microsoft keinen Bock drauf?
Dieses leaked Windows Windows 11.
Das geht wirklich?
Na, werden wir gleich sehen.
Q-Chat ist auch schon am Start.
Windows, wo ist das Problem?
Remind.
Kann man diesen komischen Dialog ausschalten?
Übrigens, ich muss euch mal was sagen.
Mich hat heute unsere, wow, wow, wow, das ist ein bisschen laggy.
Mich hat heute ganz erbost Leute von unserem Mobile Device Management Team angerufen.
Haben gesagt, sie haben immer noch nicht ihr altes iPhone XR zurückgeschickt.
Und sagt, ja, das stimmt, weil ich das neue noch nicht eingerichtet habe.
Weil die waren so schlau.
Und normalerweise kannst du, wenn du ein neues iPhone hast,
kannst du einfach über Wi-Fi oder Bluetooth,
ich weiß nicht, über was es geht, wahrscheinlich irgendeinen Wi-Fi, Ad-hoc, was auch immer,
kannst du die Settings vom alten aufs neue kopieren.
Aber das haben sie aus Security-Gründen abgeschaltet,
dass man das direkt vom alten aufs neue kopieren kann.
Und da jetzt hatte ich noch keinen Bock, mich damit auseinanderzusetzen.
Die haben gesagt, ich muss es jetzt zurückschicken,
weil sie müssen schon Strafgebühren bezahlen, weil es zu lange geleast wäre.
Ah, gut.
So, und das Problem ist jetzt...
Ah, das klappt wirklich.
Das Problem ist jetzt...
Oh, nee, nee, siehst du, Leute, man kann es doch nicht updaten.
Das geht nicht.
Geht nicht.
Das ist das Fake Windows Update.
Ach, da muss man auch Insider machen, oder was?
Dann geht's.
Insider.
Ich sehe schon, ich sehe schon, ich sehe schon.
Der Chat hat Plan.
Äh...
Diagnostics.
On.
Get started.
Okay.
Jetzt Link.
Äh, ich wollte noch irgendwas anderes gerade erzählen,
was damit zu tun hat.
Ja, und da ist mir so wieder aufgefallen,
wie kompliziert das eigentlich ist, ein iPhone zu restoren.
Wenn man nicht das direkt kopieren machen kann.
Jaja, next.
Okay, jetzt aber, Dev Channel.
Man sieht, das Plau auf Plau ist richtig gut gewählt von Microsoft, oder?
Erkennt man, erkennt man saumäßig gut.
Eastard.
So, und das Updaten über iTunes, beziehungsweise das Backupen über iTunes,
geht auch nicht richtig, haben sie mir erzählt.
Ich soll jetzt über iCloud backupen, so.
Und ich wollte vorhin, jetzt weiß ich genau, was ich erzählen wollte.
Ich wollte vorhin über iCloud backupen.
Hallo?
Hatte das jetzt nicht gecheckt, oder?
Ich wollte vorhin über iCloud backupen und da meinte iCloud,
ja, nee, nee, nee, ihr Speicherplatz ist zu niedrig.
Dann habe ich die Fotos einfach ausgeschaltet und so gebackupt.
Und ich habe jetzt nur noch drinnen die Authentificator App,
Messages und Kontakte.
Das könnten, das sind, keine Ahnung, 30 MB oder so.
Und das sagt immer noch beim Backupen, nein, geht nicht.
Sie brauchen zu viel Speicher.
Und ich vermute mal, das liegt daran, weil man Fotobackupen
nicht ausschalten kann oder weil es irgendwie verbackt ist.
Keine Ahnung, ich kriege es nicht gebacken.
Das ist wieder wahnsinnig toll gelöst.
So, darf ich jetzt?
Check for Updates.
Was will diese kacke Xbox App immer?
Alter, geht wieder nicht.
Wir haben jetzt fast alle Möglichkeiten durch.
Ich installiere jetzt doch die ISO.
Hä? Ich bin doch gerade gejoint.
Hä? What the?
Gebaidet.
Yes, Confirm, Restart Now.
Geht nicht.
Okay, gebaidet, geht nicht.
Dann machen wir jetzt, dann machen wir hier die ISO Installation.
Oh, Cutebuntu ist am Start.
Okay, das dauert drei, drei Stunden.
Wir installieren jetzt die ISO, gut.
Settings, ISO, Professional, BAM.
Neustart.
Ja, komm.
Restart.
Puller, Puller.
Hallo.
Ich will das ISO Menü haben, please.
Mountain und jetzt booten von CD.
Press any key.
Da sind wir doch.
Die chinesischen Chinesen haben meinen MS-Login.
Warum haben die?
Warum haben die das?
Du meinst, weil es sich eben nicht eingeloggt hat?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Scammed.
Time and currency Format, Germany.
Warum sieht der Installer eigentlich immer noch aus wie von Windows bis da?
I don't have a product key.
Lass mich in Ruhe, Microsoft.
Geht.
Warum ist das?
Ach so, weil ich das andere auf Deutsch gestellt habe.
Aber okay, dann lasst ihn.
Wisst ihr, das ist auch so ein Ding, was ich mich frage.
Warum kann man nicht sagen install einfach drauf?
Warum gibt es da keinen Button für so nach dem Motto?
Ja, ja, ich weiß.
Ich weiß.
Mach mal, mach mal weg und installieren neu.
Das ist zu advanced für Microsoft gewesen.
Was macht mein Upgrade auf der anderen VM?
Restart.
Hauschamp.
Gucken, ob es jetzt nach dem Restart da ist.
Wenn wir sind mit dem Stream durch, bis das andere geupdatet hat.
Aber wir sind ja hier mehr kleisig aufgestellt.
Hier läuft die Installation und da läuft das Upgrade.
Also wir können eigentlich gar nichts verkehrt machen.
Übrigens, bald ist es soweit.
Am Donnerstag.
Am Donnerstag ist es soweit.
Habe ich endlich guten Empfang.
Ich bekomme nämlich meinen ersten 5G-Chip von Bill Gates gespritzt am Donnerstag.
Donnerstag Mittag, 12 Uhr.
Wieso holst du nicht die deutsche ISO, weil ich keine deutsche ISO haben will.
Wie von Tri-Fi.
Ja, ich hoffe, dass ich nicht krank werde.
Guck mal, die Installation ist wirklich schneller als das Upgrade.
Ach, das ist noch nicht mal das Windows 11 Update.
Das ist das Kumulativ-Update.
Na dann.
Das Kumulativ-Update ist.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es dazu eine Statistik gibt.
Also in der Regel ist es so, dass umso älter du wirst.
Du eben mit allem mehr Probleme hast.
Also wäre jetzt nicht ungewöhnlich.
Bei der ersten sicher nicht.
Da kenne ich niemand, der was gespürt hat.
Na gut, weil du keinen kennst, ist das nicht sonderlich repräsentativ.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob es so offizielle Statistiken gibt, aber ich wette mit dir.
Es gibt Leute, die bei der ersten Probleme hatten.
Also ich kriege BioNTech.
BioNTech.
Vielleicht auch BioNTech.
Also BioNTech.
BioNTech.
Alles klar.
Du bekommst morgen deinen 5G-Chip Poggers.
So muss das sein.
Der Nachbar ist kurz bewusstlos geworden.
Warum das denn?
Ist er zu schnell aufgestanden oder hat er wirklich Probleme?
So und jetzt ist es jetzt.
Nee, das ist immer noch Windows 10.
Der jebaited mich.
Guck mal.
Das jebaited Hardcore.
Das geht einfach nicht.
Der macht kein Windows 11 Upgrade.
Das ist wirklich you got jebaited.
Oder will er jetzt doch?
Vielleicht will er.
Oh.
Ah, guck mal da.
Das Corelease.
Okay, drei Stunden später.
Gut, dass wir die Installation gestartet haben hier.
Also auf geht's.
Okay, wir machen das mal kurz stretched.
Und da muss ich vor allem Tools installieren, sonst geht das nicht.
Also das ist das erste schon, wo ich mich frage.
Warum hat Microsoft so ein komisches Android Style Kackmenü dahin gemacht?
Und vor allem, das gab es bei Windows 10 auch dieses Menü.
Das sah einfach nur blau aus.
Und hier ist es halt eher so Android Style.
Aber wisst ihr was ich immer noch nicht verstehe?
Dass man hier keine Tastenkombinationen drücken kann.
Warum denn nicht?
Warum kann man hier keine Tastenkombinationen drücken?
Was soll das?
Man kann hier nicht suchen.
Yes.
Wir sind in Ghana.
Stimmt, stimmt.
Jetzt habe ich mich verklickt.
Ist das Input-Method richtig?
Sag mal, Microsoft, seid ihr komplett bescheuert?
Ich habe alles auf German eingestellt.
Aber das Keyboard-Layout, das muss natürlich US sein.
Guckt mal, passt mal auf.
Und jetzt findet ihr mal das deutsche Keyboard-Layout.
Das ist so dermaßen schlecht gemacht.
Also was man sich dabei gedacht hat, ist mir ein absolutes Rätsel.
Das Design ist besser für Zoomer.
Na ja, mit einem Touchscreen würde das vielleicht auch funktionieren.
Aber so ist doch Müll.
Checking for Updates.
Kommt man da jetzt noch drumherum?
Kommt man noch um den Microsoft-Account rum?
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Muss ich auch die Netzwerk-Karte rausmachen?
Das müsste Pro sein.
Äh, nee, kommt man nicht mal drumherum.
Okay, können wir den irgendwie austricksen?
Sign-in-Options?
Alter! Wirklich! Wirklich!
Kommt mal ernsthaft.
Das ist ja sowas von heftig versteckt.
You don't know, you lack critical information. Ja, ist so.
Okay, enter your name.
Cute.
Weep.
93.
Next.
Kein Passwort.
Doch, ich finde, das ist heftig versteckt.
Übrigens, ich wollte heute, ich habe euch ja gesagt, ich wollte mein iPhone back-upen.
Und ich habe mir den Microsoft Authentic...
Wie heißt das Ding?
Einfach nur Authenticator, ne?
Drauf.
So, dann habe ich gesagt, okay, exportiere das Ganze mal iCloud.
Und dann hat Microsoft ernsthaft, pass mal auf, ich lese es euch vor.
Moment, Moment.
Das muss man sich nämlich auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Settings.
iCloud Backup.
So, also ich bin jetzt in der Authenticator App von Microsoft auf meinem iPhone.
Und gehe in die Option und sage iCloud Backup.
So, und was sagt er mir?
You need a personal Microsoft account to use Cloud Backup.
Warum brauche ich einen Microsoft account, um ein iCloud Backup zu machen von meinem iPhone?
Es gibt einfach Sachen, die versteht man nicht.
Es gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
No.
Ist das mehr geworden?
Kona Privacy, ja.
Okay, das ist immer noch einfach nur ein Reskin.
Das ist genau der gleiche Kram wie unter Windows 10.
Oh, guck mal.
Jetzt haben sie hier die highly advanced sophisticated Animationen am Start.
Warum plubber das da im Hintergrund eigentlich so rum?
Soll uns was sagen.
Hast du die neue WhatsApp Werbung schon gesehen?
Nein.
Die Werbung mit Privacy.
Also was ich bis jetzt gehört habe, ist wohl die WhatsApp Verschlüsselung.
Gibt es da wohl wenig Angriffspunkte bisher?
4 zu 3.
Ja, ich muss den Grafiktreiber klar installieren noch.
Ich meine, man hat keine Ahnung, was die wirklich machen.
Ich meine, vielleicht ist da auch was eingebaut, das sie mitlesen können, sonst wie.
Aber es haben ja schon ein paar Leute versucht zu analysieren.
Und bis jetzt hat man glaube wenig Angriffspunkte gefunden.
Bäm.
Searching for Display Treiber.
Nee, nee, musste nicht.
Musste nicht machen.
Reinstall forever Tools Bäm.
Was macht euch das Update auf der anderen VM?
Oh, guck mal hier.
Ist gar nicht so viel langsamer.
Gut, von wegen, das dauert zwei Minuten.
Was der Chat eben gesagt hat, ist vielleicht ein bisschen optimistisch gewesen.
Wir wissen ja, der Chat hat bei sowas ja prinzipiell recht.
Ich meine, könnt ihr euch an irgendeine Ereignisse erinnern, wo der Chat schon mal nicht recht hatte?
Also ich nicht.
Eigentlich immer, immer.
Battlefield 6.
Wo hatte der Chat Unrecht?
So, jetzt können wir ausmachen, dass gestretched wird.
Hallo?
Wo war das jetzt noch mal?
Hier, falschen.
Gut, jetzt Fullscreen.
Gib mir.
Jawoll.
Finish.
Restart.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt.
Dark Mode machen wir gleich.
Wir gucken uns jetzt erstmal die ganzen neuen Features an.
Also Dark Mode.
Ich glaube, ich lasse Dark Mode auch erstmal aus, weil das letzte Mal sah Dark Mode so hässlich aus.
Aber ich mache es nachher noch an, um zu gucken, ob es vielleicht jetzt besser aussieht.
Also das erste, was wir ausprobieren müssen, ist.
ETF.
Ich wollte die gerade selbst banen.
Du warst schneller.
Okay, also das sieht noch genauso aus wie Xing.
Alter Xing.
Warum?
Es geht nur nicht mal auf, wenn ich es anklicke.
Jetzt.
Moment, das ist ein Link in den Microsoft Store.
Wirklich?
Das ist beknackt.
Die Suche ist back.
Die war vorher auch schon back.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen.
Ich finde.
Ich finde es bescheuert.
Also ich muss jetzt erst mal sagen, ich finde es immer noch bescheuert, dass es so viel unterschiedliche Designs gibt.
Aber mir ist das neue hier dieses da, wenn das einheitlich wäre, lieber als das Windows 10er Standard Design.
Der Carlson.
Dankeschön für 21 Monate Hypersubscription hier.
Okay, also schauen wir mal.
Was machen denn die alten Settings?
Gibt es die immer noch?
Oh, die sehen jetzt.
Die sehen jetzt ein bisschen.
Naja, ne, ne.
Im Prinzip sehen die immer noch genauso aus wie und ist aber so.
Sie sehen vielleicht nicht exakt so aus.
Die sind jetzt ein bisschen durchsichtiger.
Die sind ein bisschen durchsichtiger, weil guck hier unter Windows 10 war das an der Seite noch nicht durchsichtig.
Jetzt sind die an der Seite durchsichtig.
Okay, falscher Bild.
Was?
Wie ist das falsche Bild?
Ich habe ich habe doch gerade.
Ich habe doch gerade installiert.
Ja.
22 00 01.
Es gibt ein neues Bild.
Was?
Ihr verarscht mich doch jetzt.
Okay, Update.
Alles updaten, alles updaten.
Da sind wir vielleicht hier doch schneller.
Die ISO ist falsch.
Das war es aktuell.
Okay, das ist wirklich langweilig.
Wieso?
Guck mal hier.
Das kann nicht vergehen.
Moment Moment.
Was habe ich denn für eine ISO 22 00 51?
Und ich habe eine ISO 22 01.
Was ist für eine Kack Seite schon wieder gewesen?
Aber vielleicht sind wir mit dem Update auf dem anderen schneller.
Okay, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass das so komplex ist.
Wir können bei der Gelegenheit auch gleich Insider joinen.
Dann gibt mal alles Microsoft.
Das ist das neue.
Okay, werden wir gleich sehen.
Ich mache Diagnostik Daten an ist gut.
Microsoft nervt nicht rum.
Get started.
Microsoft Account.
Zu wie viel Mal log ich mich da jetzt ein mit heute?
Zum sechsten Mal oder so?
Okay, Jaja, nächstes Mal.
Bitte warten.
Ich warte.
Yes.
Konfirm.
Def Channel.
Yes.
One more step restart.
Leute mit dem Restart.
Warte ich mal kurz, bis das daneben durch ist.
Das geht ja tatsächlich halbwegs, halbwegs schnell hier.
Hier sind wir schon mal 34 Prozent, also spätestens in würde ich sagen Viertelstunde sollte das auf jeden Fall da oder da fertig sein.
Ist aber schon wieder unglaublich kompliziert.
Ich meine, wir müssen bis 22 fertig sein.
Ihr wisst, was 22 ist.
22 ist Bettke.
Haben die eigentlich auch schon mal was davon gehört, dass man das parallel downloaden kann und updaten?
Oder meint ihr, das ist zu zu 2021 für Microsoft?
Ist das eigentlich schon das neue Hardware Accelerated Overlay?
Nein, ist es nicht.
Das ist noch nicht fertig.
Das müssen wir auch noch fertig machen die nächsten Tage.
Speed Champ, Speed Champ haben wir noch nicht weiter gemacht.
Müssen wir aber mal weitermachen.
Kann auch nicht alles machen.
Zeigt mal das Terminal.
Wie gesagt, ich habe noch nicht die richtige Version, aber die haben das neue Terminal mit dabei.
Das hatten sie aber auch schon in der aller allerersten Testversion.
Ok, Store Updates hindurch.
Auf, gib Gas Store.
Und jetzt Restart Now.
Oh, ist kaputt.
Ich kann im Insider Programm nicht join.
RIP.
Vielleicht mal neu starten.
Update and Restart, ok.
Warum denkst du kommt Windows 11 und die bleiben nicht bei Windows 10 Updates?
Das habe ich auch noch nicht so genau gecheckt.
Es muss aus irgendwie, also das ist eindeutig ein taktisches Release von Microsoft.
Es ist nicht, dass sich in Windows 11 jetzt so wahnsinnig fast geändert hat, dass du neues Windows machen müsstest.
Gerade nicht seit sie angefangen haben halbjährliche Updates zu bringen.
Das ist irgendein taktisches Release.
Ich habe noch nicht genau verstanden, wo, welche Taktik.
Doch, ich habe eine Channel gewählt.
Das ist standardmäßig deaf.
So ist es ist es jetzt aktuell?
Nee.
Ist es jetzt der alte oder neue Store?
Das ist der Store, da geht gar nicht mehr das.
Der ist broken.
Ok, Insider, Insider.
Oh, Passchamp.
What the fuck?
Was war das jetzt?
Es hat sich einfach instant rebooted.
Und jetzt?
Update.
Insider, hat er das jetzt gecheckt?
Wir sind doch, wir sind doch richtig, sind doch richtig.
Genau.
Ok.
Und jetzt und jetzt Update machen.
So wie sieht es bei dem anderen aus?
Hat das gecheckt?
61 Prozent.
Das ist ja laber als Fakt.
Wer hat vorhin gesagt, es geht tatsächlich in fünf Minuten?
Ah, guck mal hier, jetzt gibt es jetzt gibt es 2200051.
Die nennen es Windows 11 wegen dem Design und TPM würde ich sagen.
Natürlich gibt es mehr Gründe.
Ja, das mit dem Design ist die Sache.
Ich glaube gar nicht, dass die das wirklich machen wollten mit dem Design.
Ich glaube, die haben irgendwas gebraucht für den Noob, dass der sieht.
Ah, es ist ein neues Windows.
Und da haben sie irgendwie so halbherzig neues Design drüber gestülpt, weil alles das,
was man hier jetzt gemacht hat, dass die Settings, dass die Settings ein bisschen durchscheinen.
Wie heißt das jetzt?
Ich vergesse das immer bei Microsoft Design.
Dieses Acrylic.
Nee, Acrylic ist was anderes.
Fluent, Fluent Design.
Genau.
Das hätten wir Windows 10 auch machen können.
Die neuen Settings sind langsam brauchbar.
Das sehen wir gleich.
Oh, komm an.
Das braucht jetzt hier nicht auch noch 50 Stunden, oder?
Moment, ich muss mich da mal kurz entspannen.
Okay, gut.
Die Settings ändern sich krass in 5.1.
Ja, habe ich auch schon gehört.
Okay, weiter.
Das wird nichts.
Ja, gut.
Hey, wir können vielleicht noch ein 5.1 ISO bilden in der Zwischenzeit, dass irgendwas,
dass irgendwas passiert.
Okay, wie ist diese komische Seite, wo ich den Kram eben down?
Was habe ich eben down gelaudet für einen ISO noch?
Guck mal, downloaden irgendwie 5.1.
Guck mal, das könnte man verwenden.
Wie hieß denn nochmal diese andere?
Was?
UU.
Wie war das nochmal?
Das da, ne?
Nee.
UU.
Das da.
5.1.
Das brauche ich.
Mach die anderen VMs aus.
Ach was, das hält es schon aus.
4 Kerne, 32G RAM.
Das geht.
Es muss gehen.
So Windows.
Oh, jawoll.
Next.
So, ein.
Download.
4 Kerne, ja, 4 Kerne ist outdated.
Ich weiß, ich weiß, 4 Kerne ist outdated.
Ich hätte mir auch einen Threadripper kaufen sollen dafür.
Das war mal weg.
Ich meine, schade, nichts, wenn wir das jetzt alles parallel machen, was halt zuerst fertig
ist.
Nehmen wir.
UU.
auf Windows 11. Noch hat Windows 10 auf Windows 11 Vorsprung. Upgrade. Wir sind zurückgegangen,
war das nicht schon 85? Und hier macht er nebenbei noch einen Download, alles klar. 100% Leute,
100% und jetzt Stuck, Stuck auf 100%. Oh, das Stream ist wieder abkacken. Der Stream hat
wieder geleckt. Ich habe es genau gesehen. 100% Ja, ja, ja. Ich finde diese Windows
Progress Sachen immer, immer super. 34 und hier gibt es ein neues ISO als Nachschub. Auf Windows gibt alles.
Was macht, ich mal kurz Host System, mal kurz Host System CPU Auslastung angucken. Oh, Null.
Guck mal, ich habe es geschafft, 32 GB auszulasten. Endlich, endlich hat es sich mal
gelohnt, so viel RAM in die Kiste zu stecken. Wird ja auch mal Zeit. Jawoll, wir haben es,
fertig. Es ist fertig. Restart. Gut, dann kann ich, dann kann ich die hier mal suspenden. Dann
wird ein bisschen, wird ein bisschen RAM frei. So, und die andere? Ah, die andere ist bei 68. Na gut.
Oh, nee, jetzt, please. Windows. Windows hat jetzt schon fünfmal gesagt, es ist fertig und war nie
fertig. Na gut, es geht halbwegs schnell. Mal gucken, mal gucken, ob das jetzt wirklich fertig ist.
Der ist auch fast durch. Was macht die RAM Auslastung jetzt? Ah, okay, jetzt haben wir wieder,
jetzt haben wir wieder ein bisschen. Okay, so, und jetzt startet das neue. Und jetzt startet das mit
den neuen Settings und allem. Schauen wir mal, mal gucken, ob er jetzt fertig ist. Fast, Alter.
Vielleicht ist das hier doch schneller fertig. Jetzt bleibt er bei 0 Prozent, hat keinen Bock
mehr. 69 Prozent, ja. Vielleicht soll ich das ISO doch noch mal anwerfen hier.
Alter, okay, wenn es jetzt in der Geschwindigkeit weitergeht, ist es vorbei. Dann ist das andere
doch vorher fertig. Leute, ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es so kompliziert ist und wir
machen schon, wir machen das schon 30.000 Mal parallel hier. Zwei Prozent. Ob Windows 11 von
Windows 11 auf Windows 11 auch das gleiche machen muss. Wie öffnet man den Task Manager jetzt?
Wait, wait. Muss man jetzt hier komplett den da machen? Macht der was? Ja.
Der macht was. Was? Tatsächlich, das ist der neue Shortcut für den Task Manager. Eine Güte.
Hat dir jemand einen Tipp, wie ich eine Windows-Firm einrichten kann unter Linux,
die nicht in Slow-Motion läuft? Was meinst du mit Slow-Motion? Also ansonsten ist für
Desktop-Virtualisierung VM immer noch das Beste auch unter Linux, es sei denn du willst
irgendwelche KVM, GPU-Path-Through-Geschichten machen. Warum ist das so langsam alles? 11
Prozent. Meine Güte. Was machen wir denn? 76. Jetzt gibt er Gas. Jetzt gibt er alles hier. Jetzt
sind wir noch tief. Ja, Leute. Jetzt mal nicht so voreilig, mit welches schneller fertig wird.
Der hier gibt jetzt noch mal alles und vielleicht muss der nicht diesen ganzen Scheiß machen,
weil es ja schon Windows 11 ist. Also man kann Video schauen, aber es zerreißt das Bild andauernd.
Das ist irgendeine Tearing-Geschichte. Also wenn das mit VMWare und den VMWare-Treiber nicht geht,
würde ich sagen, das taugt nicht gescheit. Deswegen ist ja auch der Grund, warum ich so
virtualisiert habe, wie ich es virtualisiert habe. Ich habe Windows als Host und Linux als Gast,
weil es einfach viel problemloser, zumindest standardmäßig funktioniert,
als Windows als Gast und Linux als Host. Weil Linux als Host ist super,
aber Windows als Gast ist scheiße.
Restart! Bam! Was macht der andere? 11%. Oh nee, wenn der jetzt mit dem gleichen Scheiß anfängt,
ich sag's euch. Ich raste aus. He doesn't know, he lacks critical information.
Bei der Publition ist das 11 auf 11 und 10 auf 11. Das hier ist 11 auf 11 und das hier ist 10 auf 11.
Restart! Das ging schneller, das ging schneller. Das ging schon mal viel schneller als beim anderen.
Okay Leute. Guck mal, der Hachibäde, der fängt einfach später an als der andere.
Okay, schwarzer Hintergrund. Wie weit ist der andere? 19, huge.
Ich glaube, es hat funktioniert. Ich glaube, es hat funktioniert.
Siehste, Windows 11 auf 11 war doch schneller. Wie viel kostet VM-Lizenz? Das mit gar nichts.
Kannste kostenlos installieren. Also du weißt VM-Ware. Du musst mal bei Key-Shops gucken.
Offiziell bei VM-Ware ist das viel zu teuer. Okay, haben wir jetzt das richtige Bild?
Das sieht schon mal anders aus. Das sieht laggy as fuck aus. Seht ihr, wie das hier rumspackt beim
aufklicken? Warum machen die das alles so tabletmäßig jetzt? Das finde ich so nervig.
Alles ist so ver-tabletifiziert. Okay, gucken wir mal, ob das jetzt das Richtige ist. Wir können
doch gleich Terminal aufmachen. Ja, wir haben jetzt 21 H2. 2 2 0 5 1. Jetzt haben wir das Richtige.
Alles klar, sehr schön. Alles klar. Hier ist es laggy. Übrigens,
es macht einfach gar nichts. Es ist broken. Icons brauchen wir nicht. Es ist overrated,
debated, outdated. Also, gucken wir uns die neuen Settings an. Die sehen jetzt tatsächlich
anders aus. Okay. Das sind die neuen Explorer Icons. Wie sieht der Explorer jetzt aus? Okay,
wie gehabt. Oh, gibt es Tabs? Oh, guck mal da. Wir haben, nee. Wie ist das da? Das ist noch
Preview und geht nicht, oder? Vermute ich mal. Ich denke mal, es ist einfach noch kaputt. Weil
ansonsten wüsste ich nicht, wofür das hier da sein soll. Du musst in den Ordner. Ach,
dafür ist das gedacht. Ich dachte, es ist für Tabs. Das ist zum Ordner anlegen. Ja,
darauf hat die Welt gewartet. Ich dachte, das ist für neue Tabs. Mein Gott, ist das umständlich
jetzt? Fuck, Alter. Ich komme mir vor, als sitze ich an einem Tablet und nicht an meinem Desktop.
Ctrl-Shift-N, das geht bestimmt nicht, oder? Nee, natürlich nicht. Und T geht auch nicht.
Nee, gibt keine Tabs. Zumindest, zumindest. Ich wüsste sie nicht. Ernsthaft? Oh, nein. Jetzt
haben wir dafür auch zwei Versionen von dem Menü. Nein, nein, nein. Please, Microsoft. Nee,
komm. Das muss doch echt nicht sein. Okay, das ist Preview. Vielleicht fliegt das wieder raus,
aber das kann jetzt nicht euer Ernst sein. Okay, also die Settings. Was haben wir denn
Settings zu bieten? Zeig mal, wie sieht das jetzt aus? Also System, die üblichen Geschichten, Display.
Alter, das ist mega langsam. Boah, ist das langsam. Pass mal auf, pass mal auf. Kommt mal.
Noch mal zwei Sekunden, bis es aufgeht. Gut, da sage ich aber nichts dagegen. Das ist ein
Developer-Bild, das ist in Ordnung. Okay. Natürlich, das gibt es immer noch. Was sonst? Ich glaube,
das werden wir nie wegbekommen, diese Dinger. Aber okay, okay. Dann lass mal gucken, was man
hier netzwerktechnisch so einstellen kann. Ja, gut, Network durchsuchen ist natürlich
auch enorm schwierig. Es ist ja nicht, als würde es da stehen. Warum hat das jetzt fünf
Stunden für Network gebraucht? Okay, ich will jetzt mal gucken, ob ich meine IP einstellen kann.
Das DHCP-IP, okay. Ah, hier. Okay, das würde funktionieren. Schau mal gut. Aber irgendwelche
advanced Sachen wie MTU-Settings oder so geht nicht, oder? Was? Do you mean to switch app? Yes.
Okay, das ist Windows Security. Okay, all the shit ist immer noch da. Okay, das Allerwichtigste,
gibt es das Control Panel noch? Jawoll. Ich will jetzt mal so IP-Geschichten einstellen wie MTU
und so. Nur für den Fall, dass man es braucht. Manchmal braucht man sowas, ja? Wie stelle ich
MTU ein? Das geht hier drüber doch garantiert nicht, oder? Nee. Moment, wie stellt man das jetzt
ein? Bestimmt noch hier drüber, ne? Network, Internet-Settings. Das geht da, muss ich bestimmt
übers Control Panel. Ja. Okay, den Kram gibt es immer noch, wie gehabt. Das heißt, weiterhin,
wenn ich advanced Geschichten einstellen will, dann muss ich hier drüber. Wobei, konnte man,
man kann doch unter Windows bestimmt die MTU einstellen, oder nicht? Wo macht man das?
Wenn man es denn macht, wo macht man das? Bestimmt Registry-Hack.
Configure? Was? Yes. Advanced. Muss man das echt in den Treibereinstellungen machen?
Wirklich? Ja, da kann man nicht sein. Na gut. Ja, aber ich meine, zumindest kommt mir das
ein bisschen kompletter vor, als wie das jetzt unter Windows 10 ist. Ich meine, dafür hätte
es garantiert keiner als Windows gebraucht, aber es ist schon mal. So, wie sieht das mit
Energieeinstellungen aus? Ich hätte auch gedacht, dass das beim Adapter war. Ah nee,
es heißt nicht erst als Power, glaube ich. Edit Power Plan. Okay, da geht immer noch,
da geht immer noch das alte auf, wenn du auf Stromspar-Gram gehen willst. Genau. Hier sehen
wir jetzt auch wieder fünf Generationen oder 20 Jahre Windows-Generation nebeneinander.
Dark Mode, please. Ach, das geht nicht. Nein, es geht nicht, weil Windows nicht aktiviert
ist. Kein Dark Mode. Soll ich den Key posten? Du kannst mir den Key posten, aber dann leake
ich den on Stream und ich glaube nicht, dass der auch immer von wem du den Key hast, das
mag, dass du den Key leaks hier. Ach, guck mal hier. Nee, das ist was anderes, oder?
Du bist nur der Schnellste. Twitter DM kannst du mir schicken, falls ich dir folge. Gucke
mal kurz, bin ich hier eingeloggt auf Twitter? Ja, ich bin eingeloggt auf Twitter, ich folge
dir mal kurz. Ich glaube, das bist du. Ja, passt. Hollow ist raus. Okay, einfach draufklicken
ist schon mal nicht. Ich mache dann kurz Bildschirm aus, Copy Paste in den Key rein, aktiviere
Windows. Ja gut, Windows-Settings, alles schön und gut. Was macht der neue Store? Der neue
Store sieht storisch aus. Passt immer noch nicht so genau zum Rest, aber gut, was willst
du machen? Amazon. Prime Video, die hat aber gute Bewertung. Also Prime Video für Windows
scheint der eines der besten Apps aller Zeiten zu sein. Wie kann man sich die Bewertung angucken?
Raufklicken schon mal nicht. Ich würde mir gerne die Bewertung anschauen, warum die so
scheiße sind. Gibt es nicht. Rekt, darf man sich nicht angucken. Interessiert dich auch
keinen, man braucht schon Bewertung. Das ist noch nicht der neue Store, aber ich habe das
neueste Bild, ja. Das ist der alte Store. Okay, aber ich habe das richtige Bild. Get
Updates. Wie kriege ich den richtigen Store? Nochmal noch Updates. Ich habe das schon 500
Mal geupdatet heute. Ah, Moment, Key ist da. Updates. Check for Updates. Ah, jetzt macht
er wieder Updates hier. Okay, ich werde gleich mal kurz aktivieren. Du musst den Store im
Store updaten. Genau, das machen wir jetzt auch gerade. Ich weiß jetzt leider nicht
genau, was alles mit vorinstalliert ist. Ich glaube, das Terminal war vorinstalliert, aber
die Sachen hier, wir haben ja Wischl Studio und so installiert. Hatten wir nicht Wischl
Studio und Konsorten hier drauf installiert vorher? Kann das sein? Nee, ich glaube, wir
haben das auch unter Windows 11 ausprobiert. Ich glaube, der hat das komplett resettet
noch mal. Ach, stimmt, das ist die neu installierte, das ist die neu installierte VM. Ja, ja,
richtig, richtig. Updates gibt es nicht. Wir müssen warten, bis die Store Updates durch
sind. Ach, guck mal, hier, hier. Da gibt es Store Updates. Der Store kann sich selbst
updaten. Perfekt. Ich kann den Dark Mode erst gleich anmachen, wenn ich Windows aktiviert
habe. Das mache ich jetzt nach dem Neustart. Übrigens, gut, dass wir das mit dem ISO gemacht
haben, weil das hier ist wirklich alarm as fuck. Das wird überhaupt nicht fertig. So,
ist das jetzt der neue Store? Das ist der neue Store. Perfekt, guck mal hier. Der ist
jetzt abgerundet. Der ist jetzt gleich besser, weil der abgerundet ist. Library. Es sieht
aus wie irgendeine Android-Abklatsche. Das Ding. So ein Zwischending aus iOS und Android-App-Abklatsche.
Ist der Android-Emulator dann eigentlich drauf? Ich kann nicht mal tippen. Ich kann nicht
mal tippen im Startmenü. Leute, es ist broken. Es ist kaputt. Ah, wir haben es kaputt gemacht.
Ich muss mal neu starten. Meine Güte. Hallo, geh weg. Restart, Restart. Das war jetzt zu
viel auf einmal. Du musst den Amazon Store nutzen. Ja, das habe ich schon gelesen. Aber
ist der Android-Emulator denn schon dabei? Wir müssen gleich mal schauen. What's new
Insider-Preview. Was sie sich mit diesem rechteckigen WinROS-Logo gedacht haben, weiß ich auch nicht.
Das muss... Ich persönlich bin kein Fan von zu minimalistischen Alkons. Oh, guck mal.
Ist auch fast fertig. Schauen wir mal, ob... Das finde ich so lächerlich, Alter. So, darf
ich jetzt hier wieder was tippen? Jawoll, Android. Okay, nee, geht noch nicht. Color-Settings.
Wenn ich schnell bin vielleicht? Nein. Okay, activate now. Alles klar. Jaja. Change product
key. So Leute, ich werde euch mal kurz dunkel machen. Hoffen, der geht. Ja, das werden wir
jetzt sehen. Probieren wir mal aus. Next. Bravo 6 going dark. Activating Windows, best experience.
Jawoll. Die allerbeste experience. Das ist übrigens der Dark Mode, den ihr gerade seht.
Der ist einfach komplett, komplett schwarz. Windows ist activated, Leute. Wir haben es
geschafft. Da ist es. Ein aktiviertes Windows. Danke für den Key, Poggers. Jetzt können
wir uns den ganzen Kram angucken. Aktiviertes Windows, also Dark Steam. Dark Mode. So, juice
color. Dark. Okay, das sieht noch deutlich besser aus als bei der Preview-Variante. Übrigens,
das Startmenü ist abgestürzt jetzt. Das sieht deutlich besser aus als bei der Preview-Variante,
was halt immer noch ein bisschen dumm ist, dass die alten Fenster immer noch nicht checken.
Was ich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so genau verstehe, weil den Hintergrund einfach schwarz machen
hätte man auch können. Aber wahrscheinlich haben die alten Windows Anwendungen zu viel
Kontrolle drüber, wie sie aussehen, und sie könnten dadurch komplett unleserlich werden.
Jetzt hast du auf einem Scam-Account eine Windows-Lizenz. Stimmt, null. Ja, warum nicht, ne? Kann man
doch mal machen. Was haben wir denn hier? Transparency-Effects. Okay, das ist für alle Leute,
denen das zu advanced ist, wenn es überall durchschimmert. Aber den lassen wir an. Finde ich cool.
Die passende Kappa-Brite-Farbe. Ja, Windows. Äh, hallo. By the way Leute, ich mach da grad
nix, ne? Das geht komplett von alleine. Ah, jetzt, er hat's schon gemacht. Jawoll. Desktop-Icons.
Okay, das sieht immer noch genauso kacke aus wie früher. Wo ging das mit dem Colors-Endnetz
noch mal hier? Hab ich gedacht, dass es da geht, aber. Aha. Okay, das ist verbackt. Das
ist verbackt, das kackt ab, wenn das auswählt. Alles klar. So, gut, was probieren wir jetzt
aus? Erstmal alles wieder löschen. Was haben wir das letzte Mal getestet? Standardmäßig
dabei ist auf jeden Fall schon mal das neue Terminal. Das finde ich schon mal gut. Ist
WinGet standardmäßig dabei? WinGet ist auch standardmäßig dabei. Das finde ich gut.
Was macht Custom? Weiß ich. Color-Setting. Macht Custom. Da kannst du wahrscheinlich
Custom-Color picken. Oh, gucke mal. Sie haben den neuen Color-Picker, der übrigens laggt.
Und ich, also, ist das normal, dass man den nicht verschieben kann? Sie haben einen neuen
Color-Picker. Schaut euch das mal an. Krass, advanced auf Scheiß. Was die alles machen
bei Microsoft? Da war Bill persönlich wieder da. WinGet install Wishl Studio Code. Ich
weiß gar nicht, wie der richtige Installer dafür ist. Okay. No matching. Search. Es
ist nicht einfach nur Code, das weiß ich. Das habe ich nämlich das letzte Mal ausprobiert.
Es ist irgendwas anderes. Muss ich mal kurz gucken. Hier. Microsoft Wishl Studio Code
ist es halt. WinGet install. Das ist schon mal schön, dass die ein Package Manager defaultmäßig
mit ausliefern. Allerdings mal abwarten, ob das wirklich der Fall sein wird, wenn das
Ganze rauskommt. Denn bei Windows 10 hieß es ja damals auch schon, es gibt einen Package
Manager und den gab es dann bei Release gar nicht. Dass der Package Manager irgendeine
Fenster aufmachen muss, okay. Das ist Windows Installern geschuldet, da kannst du nichts
machen, kannst du nichts ändern dran. So, haben wir es jetzt installiert. Ja, passt,
doch schön. Guck mal, und er checkt auch standardmäßig, wobei, nee, ich glaube nicht, dass er standardmäßig
gecheckt hat, dass ich Darksteam habe. Das ist, glaube ich, standardmäßig hat Wishl Studio
Code einfach Darksteam. Okay, das ist doch schon mal ganz nice. Was haben wir für einen
Browser drauf? Natürlich ein Edge. Was sonst? Welcome to Edge. Alter, geh weg. Ah. Nein.
Chrome Download. Firefox Download. Ich muss weg, ich muss weg, Leute. Und ich will nicht
den deutschen Firefox downloaden, ich will den englischen Firefox downloaden. Ach, stimmt,
wir können das jetzt über Windgeld installieren. Guck mal hier, stimmt, ich bin doch, guck mal,
ich bin auch voll in diesem alten, in diesem alten Windows-Denken. Jawoll, bam. Ich meine,
da sieht man schon mal, das ist eine coole Sache, ist ein Package Manager zu haben. Haben
sie auch den Chromium oder haben sie einen Chrome? Chromium. Aber was für ein Elloson
an Google Chromium. Ja, das ist schon nice, das hat schon was. Okay, Chrome ist falsch,
ich muss wahrscheinlich sagen Google Chrome. Nee, ich muss sagen Google Chrome. Nee, einfach
nur Google.Chrome. Oder auch so. Frag mich jetzt, was er installiert. Mal gucken, was
er jetzt installiert. Aber ich gehe mal davon aus, den ganz normalen Chrome. Ein bisschen
mitdenken müssen sie ja auch, dass die Leute manchmal Mist eingeben. Jetzt hängt es, wahrscheinlich
weil er im Hintergrund Dinger macht. So, guck mal, was wir für eine Chrome Version gekriegt
haben. Ja, die normale stable. Okay, gut, nice, gefällt mir. So, jetzt können wir mal
ein neues Windows-Feature testen und zwar kann man jetzt ja, übrigens der Explorer
ist jetzt auch schön dunkel, wenn man Darkseam hat. So, es gibt jetzt ja ein neues Feature,
man kann jetzt ja hier oben irgendwie drauf gehen und kann man die Dinger undocken. Massive,
Big Brain Feature. So, das kann man auch sagen, so würde man das haben. Das soll dahin und
das soll, so, vielleicht sollte ich noch was aufmachen, keine Ahnung, das da, Edge. Ah,
das funktioniert, das funktioniert so schon mal nicht neu starten. Ah, gut. Ich, ich bin
mal ehrlich, ich glaube, ich werde dieses Feature nie verwenden. Aber, ja. Perfekt,
danke schön. Machst du, machst du Rechtsklick? Ab und zu kommt das vor, dass ich Rechtsklick
mache, ja. Aber das ist doch schon mal ganz nett. So, genau, die haben doch jetzt was
Neues. Die haben doch jetzt die neue Variante, die neue Möglichkeit, dass desktops wirklich
zum ersten Mal virtuell sind. Okay, sind sie nicht? Noch nicht anscheinend. Nee, nee, du
musst nicht Rechtsklick machen, du musst da drüber hovern. Du musst quasi Maus drüber
hovern, ne Sekunde, dann, dann geht das auf. Ist Usability technisch vielleicht auch nicht
die schönste Variante. Guck mal, das ist verbackt, das geht auch nicht. Also geht auch
nicht immer. So. Hahaha, null. Das braucht noch ein bisschen Fine Tuning, würde ich sagen,
das ganze. Diese Fensteranfall lässt sich jetzt speichern, angeblich schon. Allerdings
keine Ahnung wo, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das schon drin ist. So, das sind jetzt
die, das sind jetzt die Super AI Leute, da sind sie doch richtig drauf rumgeritten. AI
gesteuerte Newsfeed und Wetter App ist das jetzt. Es ist nicht einfach nur ne Wetter
App und einfach nur ne Newsfeed, das ist AI gesteuert, ja. Der A0er. Man kann jetzt direkt
da drauf reacten. Oh. Okay, das war's, der geht nicht. Ähm, das ist die Zeitzone. Guck
mal, wir haben ja hier jetzt ja angeblich auch 11 Uhr 44. Gucken wir mal, wie stellen
wir die Zeitzone um? Time? Time Settings. Also wir haben Pacific Time, minus 8. So und
Wirklichkeit haben wir. Ist das gerade bisschen rumgesprungen, das Fenster? Ne. In Wirklichkeit
haben wir glaube ich plus 2 gerade, ne? Oder haben wir plus 1? Haben wir denn aktuell 1?
Ich glaube gerade plus 2. Plus 1? Wir haben Sommerzeit. Aber was haben wir denn dann im
Winter? Ach plus 2 zu UTC, meine ich doch. Was denn jetzt? Ich weiß, dass ich hier klicken
muss, aber haben wir jetzt plus 1 oder plus 2? Das kann doch nicht sein, wir haben doch
jetzt vielleicht haben wir auch plus 69. So. Und jetzt? Stimmt immer noch nicht so genau.
Jaja, das ist richtig. Vielleicht braucht es, vielleicht braucht es jetzt einfach ein
bisschen. Ah jetzt, jetzt hat er es gecheckt, alles klar. Daylight Saving Time, ja das ist
noch mal plus 1. Das ist plus 1 plus 1 quasi gerade. Wir sind nämlich gerade plus 2. Hast
du schon das neue Action Center gesehen? Du meinst das da neben? Ne. Wo? Äh, ok. Ah,
ok. Alles klar. Passt. Gut. Warum kann ich das hier? Videos? Action. Ja du meinst schon
das, was hier eben aufgeht. Warum das jetzt allerdings? Ich weiß es nicht. Ok, das Notification
Center finde ich schon mal besser. Lautstärke, genau. Es ist ziemlich laggy beim Aufgehen.
Nightlight? Seht ihr irgendwas? Ne, auch noch passiert nichts. Was ist denn Priority Only,
Alarms Only? Ok, Nightlight macht schon mal nichts. Ähm, stimmt. Ach stimmt ihr seht
nichts unten rechts. Lull, ja. Wartet mal. Ich mach euch mal aus. Der Kalender. Ja, ich
sollte gucken Audio Settings. Wie kriegt man hier jetzt einen Mixer? Open Volume Mixer?
Die Fenster glitschen noch ziemlich ineinander. So und wo kann ich jetzt zum Beispiel einstellen?
Ähm, wie der Sampling Rate von meinem Audio? Gar nichts. Wurde weg rationalisiert oder
wie? Aha. Ähm, Advanced? Because? Ähm, ja. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok. Ok.
Hm. Gibt es da sowas wie Advanced Settings? Ach guck mal da. Das ist mega delayed, das
ist brutal langsam. Ich klick drauf und zwei Sekunden später passiert was. Ok. Ja, das
ist in Ordnung. Das ist gut, dass das jetzt funktioniert. Ok, das wird ein bisschen dauern
bis ich mich da zurecht finde. Aber das ist alles Gewöhnungssache. Das ist schon in
Ordnung wie das jetzt ist. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, was ich halt ein bisschen, was ich
bisher noch nie mochte an den neuen Settings. Ähm, ich finde die einzelnen Gruppierungen
und Dinge, das hebt sich viel zu schlecht voneinander ab. Du hast quasi mehr oder weniger
alles hier auf einer Page und du weißt gar nicht so genau wo du gucken musst für irgendwas.
Klar, das ist letztendlich Gewöhnungssache. Wenn ich 50 mal hier geklickt habe, dann weiß
ich auch, dass ich da klicken muss. Vielleicht gibt es die alten Audio Settings überhaupt
noch. Gucken wir mal, Control Panel. Doch hier. Ah, die gibt es noch. Die gibt es noch.
Ich fand, ich muss halt, das ist jetzt echt schwer einzuschätzen, ja. Weil es ist halt
viel Gewöhnungssache bei. Aber mein Bauchgefühl nach, würde ich sagen, das ist immer noch,
auch vielleicht wenn es nicht so schick ist, immer noch die übersichtlichere Variante.
Du weißt halt genau wo was steht. Aber da ist halt auch viel Gewöhnung und Übung bei,
weil das halt schon seit 20 Jahren so aussieht. Oh, den Chat. Aninstall. Ok, das gibt es immer
noch. Ich glaube, das wird uns auch auf ewig begleiten. Das Control Panel Menü. Animationen
sind nicht GPU Accelerator, das kann sein. Aber die Animationen an sich sind ja flüssig,
halbwegs. Aber der Rest ist halt übelst langsam hier. Oh ja, HDR, HDR muss unbedingt eingeschaltet
werden. NRVM. Gibt es jetzt einen integrierten Lautstärke Mixer? Stimmt, da haben wir noch
nicht danach geguckt. Aber ich habe sowas eben gesehen, ja. Übrigens auch merkwürdig,
dass das alles hier ein Feld ist. Aber hier Kontextbasiert das kommt und hier Kontextbasiert
das kommt. Aber ok. Volume Mixer. Warum genau geht das alte Control Panel nicht weg? Weil
da wahrscheinlich immer noch Settings drin sind, die nirgends woanders sind. Und wo ist
jetzt der Mixer? Ok, da muss ich jetzt mal mehrere Programme starten, die Sounds abspielen.
Machen wir mal ein Chrome. Ja, sowas hier. Sound. Ah, schön Werbung. Ah, hier guck mal,
es gibt einen integrierten Sound Mixer anscheinend. Das gab es aber auch in der Windows 10 schon.
Will ich mir ein dieses Ding, oder? Oder nicht? Hä? Boah! Lagi AF! Oh, das ist cool.
ich habe es kaputt gemacht leute, procken, procken
ich mache nochmal neu auf
so, das finde ich ganz cool, dass man hier jetzt für jedes einzelne Programm die Devices
einstellen kann, das geht zum größten Teil jetzt schon, aber da muss man glaube ich
das in dem jeweiligen Programm einstellen, dass man das global einstellen kann ist natürlich
praktisch
Privacy Settings, erstmal so unübersichtlich gemacht, dass du gar nicht weißt was da Sache
ist, ich finde das immer noch unübersichtlich, oh leute großes problem, die Fenster gehen
nicht immer zu wenn man oben links in die Ecke drückt, das ist aber vielleicht noch
ein bug, ne jetzt funktioniert es, jetzt funktioniert es eben, eben hat es nicht funktioniert, aber
gut
ok, was haben wir denn das letzte mal noch geguckt, wir hatten noch eine Visual Studio
Preview installiert, das kann man jetzt aber wahrscheinlich sparen, weil das haben wir
das letzte mal schon ausprobiert und es ging einfach, das sieht doch alles aus wie gehabt
Werbung please, Geld YouTube Premium, ich habe übrigens YouTube Premium bei mir auf dem Handy,
beziehungsweise auf dem anderen YouTube Account den ich extra für Smartphone habe, da habe
ich indisches YouTube Premium, 350 Rupien oder sowas hat es gekostet, irgendwie 3 Euro,
das ist halt fast nichts und ich glaube hier in Deutschland kostet glaube ich, wie viel
kostet das, 13 oder 14,99 oder sowas, WSL genau, wie es da aussieht, ob das jetzt einfach
funktioniert, WSL, install, ok ja, haha, null, funktioniert nicht, Moment, ah ich habe schon
gedacht, ich habe schon gedacht es funktioniert, weil es so lange gebraucht hat, aber top,
wie macht man das als Admin jetzt auf, so, ich habe schon kurz gedacht es funktioniert,
aber WSL install funktioniert besser als vorher, vorher musstest du ja an 3 verschiedenen
Stellen klicken, kernel updaten hin und her und hast du nicht gesehen, ach guck mal sie
installieren sogar GUI Support mit, das werden wir jetzt gleich ausprobieren ob der GUI Support
auch direkt funktioniert, xis, wenn xis funktioniert ist alles gut, wichtigstes Linux Programm,
nach ascii aquarium, das ist kein sudo equivalent, gibt es trotzdem armselig, ja ich verstehe
auch nicht warum, nein windgate war standardmäßig mit drauf, welche WSL Version ist default,
nachdem auch vm support installiert, vm support installiert ist denke ich mal zweier default,
gibt es schon Windows Features in Windows 11, ja, aber eher optische Dinger, wie es
mit Hyper-V aussieht habe ich keine Ahnung, gibt es noch diesen Sandbox vm, oder wie hieß
denn das nochmal, ist das nicht Sandbox, wie die standardmäßig jetzt mitkommt, ok hat
er jetzt Ubuntu drauf gemacht, ne Moment was muss ich jetzt, was, warte mal wenn WSL installiert
ist, da muss ich jetzt in Shop und Ubuntu installieren, ne, da muss ich jetzt Moment,
Moment, Moment ich muss installieren, wo ist der Sound, Reboot, ok wenn ich Reboot machen
muss noch mal Reboot, Reboot kann man nicht oft genug machen, übrigens der Reboot Bildschirm
ist jetzt schwarz, mal gucken ob der, wir testen noch den Blue Screen, wir verursachen
jetzt den Blue Screen, wir verursachen jetzt noch den Blue Screen, mal gucken wie das funktioniert,
wie hieß denn das noch, wir haben das letzte Mal ins Zenith Crash, ne, es gab da eben so
ein Sysinternals Tool für Blue Screens, es gab irgendein Sysinternals Tool, da konntest
du direkt kernel crash machen, not my fault, ja das kann sein, das ist das wahr, ja, ist
es das Chain Law, weiß nicht, Blue Screen Screensaver, Quatsch, beim Chain Law bin
ich mir da nie so sicher, ob der das einfach nur nicht gesehen hat oder ob der trollt,
das weiß man bei ihm nie so genau, ok dann hat er gebadet, manchmal schreibt er aber
auch Dinger wo ich mir denke, das kann er doch nicht ernst meinen und die meint er dann
einst, ok, not my fault war das genau, oh Installing Jubandu, komm mal jetzt kann man
hier eigenen Hintergrund pro Desktop Design, was heißt Design, auswählen, das finde ich
schonmal cool, ne, kann man doch nicht, gebadet, das soll aber, ne, ne, ne, guck mal hier,
eigenen Hintergrund pro Desktop, ok das haben sie schon gemacht, aber eigene Icons gehen
noch nicht, das wollten sie ja, das wollten sie ja noch machen, jaja, haben wir, ok, Moment,
Moment, Moment, ich brauche das ordentliche Terminal, ah viel besser, so und jetzt einmal
Power, nicht PowerShell, Ding starten, WSL, sehr gut, exzellent, exzellent, abinstall xis,
ne das war x11 Utils oder sowas, glaub was man da braucht, ne x11 Apps, so, mal gucken,
mal gucken ob gleich die grafischen, die grafischen Linux Apps funktionieren xis und und und und
undCHEERING, vielleicht kommt das auch auf dem anderen Desktop, es hat bestimmt kein Multi
Desktop Support, ich mache mal, ich mache mal kurz alles wieder zu, geh mal auf Desktop
eins so das war das multiple desktop support ist wahrscheinlich zu viel dafür
x es geht nicht tut sich nix also mit den grafischen anwender funktioniert nicht so
richtig muss wahrscheinlich noch den x-server auf winz aus nein muss man nicht mehr die haben
jetzt einen dabei das hat einfach nur drei stunden gedauert aber es ist immer noch verbackt
es ist immer noch verbackt
es ist immer noch verbackt ok gelix gears läuft das mittlerweile in der
ich könnte mir vorstellen es läuft normalerweise aber halt nicht in der vm erst mal update
wenn du da jetzt den file explorer aufmachst kannst du dann davon windows dateien rein sind
das probieren wir jetzt mal aus ich glaube ich glaube nicht das ist wenn aus 11 war sie
mehr oder weniger so wie wenn es selbst installiert dass das mit dem file manager probieren wir jetzt
aber ich glaube nicht dass das funktioniert ok gelix gears giert rum so vor sich hin und
ist abkacken also 3d beschleunigung klappt noch nicht aber das kann auch an meiner vm liegen das
kann das kann durchaus an der vm liegen muss man mal gucken wie das wirklich also wie das wie
das auf hardware funktioniert übrigens wisst ihr dass die hässlichste die hässlichste feuer demo
aller zeiten ist gar nicht mehr dabei ok na gut ok guck mal wie das mit dem file manager
funktioniert ein bisschen was realistische was war das feier was was ich einfach nur feier
was sind das das kenne ich gar nicht ist das das was ich denke
bitte zeigen im windows explorer gibt es jetzt ein linux bereich das stimmt das ist mir sogar
schon in der allerersten testversion aufgefallen dass man hier jetzt direkt auf den ordner kommt
wo sein wsl drin liegt beziehungsweise dass man das stimmt ja so nicht das ist jetzt eine vm dass
man direkt quasi das linux laufwerk irgendwie gemacht hat das ist tatsächlich ganz praktisch
für einen datei austausch aber umgedreht wäre natürlich auch cool was für ein x-server benutzt
zu denen der dabei ist bei ich habe es mal hinzugefügt den da jetzt dabei ist bei windows 11 jetzt einer
dabei muss man sich nicht mehr mit komischen trittanbietern x-server rumschlagen was wenn
ich mir windows 11 drauf mache kann ich dann später auf das neuste abgränen ja wahrscheinlich
schon wahrscheinlich schon du musst aber insider bild aktuell noch machen ob du natürlich auf
release upgraden kannst keine ahnung ich könnte mir vorstellen dass es geht aber keine ahnung
das weiß nur microsoft ob das möglich sein wird ja donnerstag ist es bei mir so weit erster
5g chip von bill gates ist am start man kommt das elfer offiziell raus ich bin mir gar nicht
sicher haben die da was zugesagt ich bilde mir ein im november habe ich was gelesen oder ende
des jahres aber ich weiß nicht ob die offiziell was gesagt oktober oktober ist ja noch ist ja
nicht mehr so lang es ist august september oktober noch noch drei monate auf jetzt mal
mal hinne hier coming this fall ja das ist herbst also irgendwann sagen wir mal selbst
soll sich sagen wir mal irgendwann ende des jahres ich bin übrigens immer noch gespannt
wie die den anreiz setzen wollen also wenn ich auf windows 11 upgraden kann ohne neuinstallation
und ohne alles und es funktioniert gut mache ich vielleicht ansonsten sehe ich aktuell
zumindest jetzt unmittelbar noch nicht die großen vorteile also weil gerade so diese
mega verteplettifizierung von diesen menus hier und sowas naja naja
so die rib geht nicht so linux file manager mal aufmachen sieht da mega mega nice aus
create folder 0 b aber es funktioniert ich meine es sind die linux anwendungen direkt
unter unter direkt unter windows hier linux anwendung ist ok das geht nicht oder wenn
das geht hat das jetzt funktioniert das kann ich funktioniert haben das ist da unten für
ein fenster ne ne ne das funktioniert nicht copy ne das funktioniert nicht das wäre aber
auch sehr merkwürdig hätte das jetzt funktioniert ja vielleicht vielleicht fehlt ich meine
es ist es ist immerhin es ist windows vielleicht fehlt ja ne endung ok ne ne klappt nicht aber
hätte mich auch sehr gewundert auf der anderen seite ist jetzt gar nicht so schlimm man kann
jetzt ja hier drüber gehen dann haben wir home max leckt und da hat man hier die datei
immerhin das ist das ist schon das ist schon in ordnung also wenn man sagt dass hier das
hier ist die linux welt ich kann es jetzt hier im notepad öffnen was übrigens keiner empfehlen
würde mit windows editor an text dateien rum zu würsten und jetzt und jetzt ist das hier
drin das funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut was gibt es denn sonst noch schönes was man
gucken muss gibt es eigentlich noch den classic design mode das ist eine gute frage du meinst
das was aussieht wie bin aus 2000 das glaube ich nicht dass es noch drinne ist ne wahrscheinlich
nicht wie hat man das früher gemacht warum ist doch nur eine text datei weil zeit weil
zeilen endung zwischen linux und windows unterschiedlich sind oder ich weiß ich ob das notepad mittlerweile
auch kann schauen wir mal ich weiß ich linux kann es wahrscheinlich mit den windows zeilen
endung mittlerweile environment settings ist das das habe ich noch nie gemacht wo ist das
zeigt mal hier da müsst ihr mir jetzt zeigen wo ich hin muss wo kriege ich jetzt wo kriege
ich die klasse classic mode eingestellt das erste settings ok
das aus und dann so ok das das wird eklig als fack aussehen
pass mal auf ich weiß jetzt nicht ob das wirklich classic mode ist es läuft aber in der tarte
ein bisschen ein bisschen schneller ja aber so ist natürlich so ist natürlich mehr fancy
ne paar animationen weniger ja hier lags übrigens immer noch auch ganz ohne animation naja
vielleicht gibt es das auch nicht mehr vielleicht wie gesagt vielleicht gibt es das auch nicht
mehr ich weiß was du meinst du meinst das was dann aus wie bin aus 2000 ich glaube das
gibt es nicht mehr vorbei kannst du mal versuchen open shell zu installieren ne das ist dieses
alternative startmenü das hat mir das hat mir noch nie gefallen gut ich mein wenn ich
mir das hier angucke vielleicht gebe ich mir das dann auch ich sagen muss so schlecht ist
das doch gar nicht so mein hauptsache das wichtigste ist doch ist ernsthaft das wichtigste
ist dass man hier drin suchen kann ich mein so ein crappy wordpad braucht man natürlich
nicht aber was macht eigentlich paint von der optik her ok paint sieht genauso aus wie
vorhaben personally keck weh lull next kann jetzt office verwenden oh go premium free office
free office ich will kein premium lass mich nur microsoft yes yes mach mach mach mach
ist das ist das quasi eine elektron anwendung sehe ich das jetzt richtig ist das hier in
den browser ist das hier in den browser der einfach nur so und dass das office skype das
ist das ist einfach nur einfach elektron oder man kann es gar nicht öffnen was das
für ein schwachsinn office und jetzt kann man das gar nicht editieren oder was ok das
ist fail das ist nur ein viewer ja gut den meisten den meisten leuten reicht es wahrscheinlich
aber das ist das ist dann rein online da ist bei mir nichts lokal naja gut gut who cares
who cares ich verwende den kram eh nicht ich verwende den kram eh nicht das ist eigentlich
alles dabei oh point outlook one drive teams ok das teams ist jetzt ja ergeblich besser
integriert checking your credentials wo kommt man dabei teams denn raus wenn man sich da
einloggt never g baited g baited jetzt vorbei jetzt jetzt komme ich mit meinem test account
nicht weiter jetzt vorbei gut dann so eine komische to do app alles klar dass natürlich
eine eigene app ist inkonsistenz können sie aber alles in allem ich muss sagen das sieht
schon besser aus als die preview version die preview version war ja wirklich nahenlos
zusammengestöckel des zeug gut chat was was was wollen wir was wollen wir noch gucken
es gibt ich suche mal was es für features noch gibt weil zweites video weiß ich nicht
ob ich dazu was aufnehmen soll das glaube ich so spannend oder funktioniert maus mittel
klick bei dir um eine neue instanz von der taskleiste zu öffnen was mach grad mittel
klick hier drauf da passiert nichts wie sieht wie soll eine neue instanz der taskleiste
aussehen habe ich der ganze bildschirm voller taskleisten was so viel mit mit sp 32 haben
wir sogar im stream schon einiges gemacht so was wollte ich jetzt ausprobieren genau
windows 10 was war das 2000 was new ich aber nicht für noch 10 11 eingeben mittel klick
auf den explorer das scheint zu funktionieren ja es lag zwar ganz schön wenn man das ach
du scheiße leute zwar keine gute idee wir bringen wir noch an seine grenzen mal gucken
was es jetzt macht so finde ich habe finger weg jetzt vorbei monka bluescreen ist zu viel
ach stimmt wir wollten ja den pluscreen angucken genau not my fault pluscreen genau das brauche
man laut new action center ok was was gibt es da neues ach so das ist youtube hallo in
diesem video nur ganz kurz das neue windows 11 bild 2251 announcing insider preview gibt
es denn gut das haben wir uns schon angeguckt das wissen wir startmenü haben wir uns eingeguckt
taskbar notification alles klar file explorer haben wir gesehen er hat jetzt runde ecken
sounds adi sounds sind jetzt anders ich habe nicht ein sound gehört oh excellent wie kann
man wo kann man die sich anhören ist im sounds ok keine ahnung warum es keine tabs gibt ich
weiß es nicht vielleicht vielleicht kommt das noch so wir gucken uns jetzt noch mal
schnell den pluscreen an wie der pluscreen so aussieht es ist achtung bm der pluscreen
ist immer noch blu wer hat gesagt der pluscreen ist nicht mal blu stimmt überhaupt nicht
pack news
fake news
das gibt es ja eigentlich auch für unterschiedliche dinger das ist die kommandozahlenversion
und das ist die 64 bit kommandozahlenversion das ist die 32 bit version kann ich ein 32
bit pluscreen unter windows 64 ja geht immer noch ok gut für pluscreen ist egal ob 32
oder 64 bit
aber der pluscreen sieht nicht wirklich merklich anders aus als jetzt schon
kannst du mal zeigen wie die symbolen der taskleister aussehen wenn sie aufgeklappt
sind du meinst wenn man hier mehrere sachen gleichzeitig auf hat so wie der laggy explorer
so also so wie unter windows 10 was wir jetzt einmal gucken können taskbar settings wir
haben es jetzt hier aktiviert wir haben es jetzt hier aktiviert was man da wieder ob
man da was ordentliches einstellen kann jetzt wieder kann man die taskleiste links einstellen
warum warum kann man nicht warum kann man nicht bottom left top left einstellen weil
ich meine es gibt immer noch einige leute ich kenne sogar ein paar die haben das gerne
oben die ansicht wo alle die symbole nicht klein sondern ausgeklappt sind was wo alle
symbole nicht klein sondern ausgeklappt ich habe keine ahnung was du meinst ja ja das
liegt das liegt zum größten also ich denke auch dass zum größten teil an der vm liegt
kann man die nach oben ziehen geht doch gar nicht mehr geht doch gar nicht mehr du kannst
du hast ja keine freie freie move bar settings mehr es geht nicht mehr
also was für mich wichtig wäre dass man das gruppieren ausschalten kann
seht ihr irgendwo was um das gruppieren auszuschalten
anscheinend nicht oder
gruppieren ausschalten gibt es auch komm und
das ist das erste was ich immer ausschalte dass das weil mich nervt das ich ich mag
das nicht guck mal hier ist so viel platz warum warum kann man nicht einfach den benutzen
für für die ganzen fenster ich habe beispielsweise immer drei stück drei stück text editor
oder sowas auf na gut drei text editor sind falsches beispiel da hat man tabs drinne mittlerweile
aber ich gerade beim explorer nervt mich na gut was ist das task view was oben aktiviert
ist das ist dass man dass man das da oder so angezeigt bekommt was ist eigentlich aus
der windows history geworden es gab doch so eine history wenn man die aufgemacht hat konnte
man so durch dann durch scrollen was man in letzter zeit auf und zu gemacht hat gibt es
es nicht mehr die wurde entfernt weil das das gibt es doch noch gar nicht so lang timeline
hieß das genau das geht das gab es doch auch erst ein jahr oder so dat okay die haben alles
ausgebaut touch keyboard jawoll genau das brauche ich oh jawoll endlich hallo das habe ich
gebraucht ganz wichtig ach ja moment der allerwichtigste test kann notepad jetzt farbige emojis nein
rib uninstall refund einstern also dass das nicht geht shitware genau das wichtigste das
wichtigste geht wieder nicht moment kann wordpad wordpad farbige emojis ich vermute auch nicht
weil das alles der gleiche alle kram ist nein ok kann office kann office das ok das ist
ja im browser die office war immer klar klar kann es das im browser dass sie keinen sinnvollen
editor als stand haben die könnten doch eigentlich echt visual studio code standardmäßig ausliefern
oder wenn die können ja meinetwegen notepad dabei lassen ich weiß die leute raging übelst
rum wenn notepad nicht dabei ist genauso wie sie gesagt haben pain kommt raus da sind die
leute auch alle total eskaliert hier geht farbige emojis alles klar wie es kaut ist
halt nicht für casual gut warum nicht ich meine das ist ein editor wo du was reinschreiben
kannst und speichern sie können ja notepad dabei lassen aber
wordpad können sie rausschmeißen ich mein wordpad mal ernsthaft gibt es wirklich irgendjemand
der diesen shit verwendet nein wordpad alter insert object alles klar kein problem ein
paintbrush picture euer hier jetzt sind wir aber hier ganz advanced bei windows am start
hier ist das nicht geil einfach lieber office nutzen auch wenn wir mal was richtig hässliches
sehen wollen dann gucken wir uns lieber office unter windows 11 an ich meine das ding sieht
normalerweise schon kacke aus aber unter windows 11 wird es wahrscheinlich nochmal doppelt
beschissen aussehen lieber office benutze ich auch ab und zu wenn ich office benutzen
muss aber ihr wisst ja ich verwende eigentlich fast nix office aber hübsch ist es nicht
ach stimmt win get leute ich muss mich da unter windows echt dran gewöhnen ich muss
mich da echt dran gewöhnen moment wir waren das terminal auf win get search erstmal gucken
not my fault ob es den kram zum installieren gibt nein äh lieber office of fools die website
sieht schon scheiße aus ja es sehen aber viele open source project websites also vor allem
schon die bisschen älteren open source project websites sehen fast alle kacke aus nur die
neuen hippen elektron anwendung nicht die pro office lieber office am schl... ja ich
bei strike lustigerweise ich wollte es gerade sagen am hässlichsten sind die bsd webseiten
guckt euch das mal an passt mal auf achtung achtung augenkrebs inc open bsd org der hat
aus irgendwelchen gründen dark theme standardmäßig normalerweise nicht das rack von 1995 alter
ich glaube die ist schon absichtlich so schlecht oder ich glaube die lassen das absichtlich
so net bsd ist modern die kann man sich tatsächlich angucken was war free bsd so gibt es das überhaupt
noch ok so dazwischen so dazwischen aber open bsd ist schon drin was installer exit warum
die pro office konnte nicht installiert werden leute es ist kaputt und jetzt lädt das nochmal
runter hat kein cash cash is overrated outdated jebaited als admin der sollte mich nach admin
rechten fragen der sollte mich eigentlich nach admin rechten fragen und nicht das termin als
admin starten müssen wir können es mal ausprobieren ob es als admin geht aber wenn es richtig
gemacht wird würde der mich nach admin rechten fragen ok schauen wir mal wie ging das shift
klick nee schipp schiff klick ich habe es jetzt mit schift gemacht woher weiß ich jetzt
ob es admin rechte hat woher sehe ich das jetzt ob das jetzt der admin shell ist oder
nicht das steht im tap also ist das also ist das keine pow also ist das keine admin shell
also was control shift und draufklicken 20 tasten kombi ist hier install was liebe off
ist liebe off ist ob das jetzt als admin funktioniert ich meine so einen cash wäre
was oder einen cash für downloads das das das hätte schon was dass sie jedes mal alles
neu runterladen muss moment was ist los kelmore windows powershell magic hier chat ist abgekackt
weil meine rammauslastung zu hoch war vorhin hier big brain big brain time jetzt leute
richtig richtig big brain time tru tru 0w alles klar wusste ich das zeigt mir an ob
man admin hat oder nicht das heißt hier zeigt es falls an es kopiert schon nicht mehr falls
tatsächlich security principle windows identikit groups contain das ist die group id von der
admin gruppe easy weiß man doch weiß man doch ich weiß warum nennt man die admin gruppe
nicht einfach admin das war das zu einfach wie wäre es wenn man einfach contains admin
schreiben könnte oder so ach das funktioniert ok dann ist das install script für win get
kaputt IQ Hackermanns ja komm mal jetzt installiert er LibroOffice dann ist das install script
für win get kaputt da sind die aber selber dran schuld da können die win get entwickler
nichts für da sind die da sind die selber dran schuld weil die so einen installer wildwuchs
hatten übrigens wisst ihr was ich gelesen habe ich habe gelesen dass microsoft selbst
keinen bock mehr auf uwp hat winui 3 das ist ja so das neue windows gui zeug hier und die
haben keinen bock mehr auf uwp haben sie selbst letztens geschrieben also uwp uwp ist ist
anscheinend rip winui uwp ich weiß ich wo ich gelesen habe genau die haben keinen bock
mehr winui 3 war eigentlich gedacht dass man native anwendung machen kann also win 32 anwendung
sowas wie windows forms oder so halt mit mit diesem neuen gui zeug und und uwp aber uwp
ist jetzt rip zum glück niemand mag uwp ok es sieht immer noch hässlich aus aber es
funktioniert 1995 will sein jui wieder haben woodface alter richtig
der typ der uwp heißt das stimmt generell ist uwp ein ziemlich blöder name wenn man
mit englischsprachigen leuten kommuniziert die die können uwe können die überhaupt
nicht aussprechen uwi uwi uwi die kriegen das nicht hin also uwe uwe ist für englischsprachige
leute der teufel uwi die kriegen das nicht hin kann ich vergessen uwi uwi uwi das geht
nicht also also das ist wirklich ein name haben die große probleme mit ich einmal monka
windows benutzt heute hast du schon vom msi x gehört ja das problem ist das msi ist ja
dass das was die auch für uwp mal pushen wollten mein hauptproblem mit bundled apps
unter anderem uwp gehörte dazu ist man braucht ein gültiges code signing zertifikat und
niemand hat ein gültiges code signing zertifikat das eine du bist ein software entwickler firma
was ist eigentlich tmp 2 0 woran die wir noch selbst binden wollen irgendein security dinge
auf dem mainboard irgendwas wo du wo du irgendwelche security keys hinterlegen frag mich nicht
keine ahnung das ist trusted trusted was ist das platform module nee was ist uwe was
ist tmp tmp trusted platform module gibt schon ein video treiber für windows 11 ich würde
sagen die windows 10 treiber funktionieren wunderbar das kann ich jetzt hier nicht aus
probieren weil es eine vm ist warum warum habe ich eigentlich den japanischen kalender
ok ich weiß nicht ob es japanisch ist es könnte auch koreanisch sein oder vietnamesisch
oder so oder oder china chinesisch warum ist denn warum ist er japanisch man hört eigentlich
die welt auf laut windows zeigt mal her ok nicht so schnell links tastatur bedienung
geht nicht im chat naja ich mein komm unser account ist von der cute wieb 3 90 da kann
eigentlich nichts schief gehen so was wollte ich jetzt noch ausprobieren leute wollte ich
irgendwas ausprobieren sagt man wollte ich etwas ausprobieren oder
wollt ihr noch irgendwas sehen wollen etwas ausprobieren neu finde aus elf inzwischen
auf echte hardware jaja ja ja macht
eine mit linux habe ich ausprobiert funktioniert wenn du es über den explorer machst alles
gut hier über den explorer gibt es jetzt unten standardmäßig den mount für dann
wsl geht umgedreht aus dem linux datei exui datei explorer geht nicht aber das hat mich
auch sehr gewundert fazit zu windows 11 ist schon mal viel besser als die preview version
die es da gab rechedit ja klar das gibt es immer noch da muss man sich nicht das wird
sich nie ändern 123 alles klar ist das andere eigentlich mittlerweile durch oh kommt mal
hier wir haben geupdatet das hat funktioniert
andere ist durch kann ich mal pausieren
wann das offiziell released werden soll ende des jahres irgendwie oktober november kann
man unter linux per mv nach windows kopieren ja ja das geht wenn du das in richtigen ordner
machst funktioniert das da guck hier wenn ich hier habe ich habe ich habe ich nicht
noch in den wsl offen gehabt gerade
das funktioniert du kannst sogar noch besser machen guck mal du kannst sag mal du gehst
jetzt in den ordner rein und legst jetzt eine datei an touch blub du kannst sogar sagen
jetzt explorer hier aufmachen dann hast du die datei hier direkt im windows explorer
das ist eigentlich ganz cool ja und du kannst die auch du kannst die auch zp wenn du die
hierhin zp ist das funktioniert gibt's windows g noch windows g ist das das
ist die xbox game bar audio mix ok wie krieg ich es wie krieg ich es wieder
weg wie krieg ich es ok das ist einfach weg
nee das ist nicht für xbox das ist so so eine art overlay das ist das ding was von
ein paar windows version lex verursacht hat in spielen aber jetzt angeblich angeblich
ich kann da nicht aus eigener erfahrung sprechen ganz brauchbar sein soll die neue xbox apple
ist auch am start neuer store ist am start mit direkt indikiert im game pass also ja
das wird sich dann zeigen ob ich das verwende ich gehe mal davon aus steam steam wird immer
noch war das denn jetzt gerade steps recorder und was was ist das für uralt ding was was
deptender und da jetzt macht stop was macht es denn jetzt ach das ist so ein support ding
ach das ist so ein support ding wo ich dann sagen kann guck wenn ich das jetzt klicke
dann ist kaputt ok schon nie verwendet das ist wenn du peta vom microsoft support anrufst
dann brauchst du das verstanden verstanden das neue windows explorer gui besser anders
was mich ja noch extrem nervt aber da hoffe ich mal dass sie das nicht nicht drinnen behalten
du hast jetzt das neue menu was mega tablet style ich aussieht bin ich ja gar kein fan
von wisst ihr aber du hast hier unten immer noch den knopf für das alte menu das finde
ich ziemlich fehl ja ich will gar nicht sagen dass die dass msi x da keine guten features
hat aber dieses ganze also die idee ist ja alles auch gut auch auch vom ansatz her fand
ich das mit uwp gar nicht so doof aber dass du ein gültiges code signing zertifikat
brauchst ist halt so der der für mich der ko punkt und ich glaube so der der punkt
in viele hatten gut was viele auch noch an uwp genervt hat ist dass du vieles nicht
machen konntest ich glaube du kannst bis heute keine screenshots machen richtig in uwp vielleicht
möglich dass es jetzt geht aber spätestens screen recorder in uwp programmieren geht
halt nicht stammt aus der zeit wo microsoft der meinung war sie müssen windows unbedingt
tablet tablet mäßig machen und jetzt ist es so halbherzig jetzt hast du hier so komische
ta ich mein was denkt man sich bei diesen bei diesen komischen tablet menus das ist
ein desktop den ich mit mausentastatur bediene ich brauche keine tablet menu bedienung weil
ich das in an sich ja von der aufteilung in eigens her durchaus in ordnung findet ja
warum ist virtualbox so viel langsamer ich würde mal sagen oracle das sollte
sich adaptiv anpassen ja sehe ich auch so ich habe gar nichts dagegen wenn man sein
betriebssystem touch besser touch bedienbar macht schift schift f11 was macht das denn
das ist das alte menu ok ja gut das alte menu kriege ich ja so auch noch
ach stimmt ja hier steht ja das ist eine kombination
und schweifberg gab ja unbedingt ganz ganz wichtig für mich jetzt space left ich will
nicht sunken nein was ist denn in pictures überhaupt drin nix ich will nicht backup ok
was gibt es sonst noch auszuprobieren wir haben noch eine stunde zeit funktioniert
all der vier noch ja das funktioniert noch was funs noch ein bisschen fail dass die dinge
oftmals so mit weißem hintergrund aufgehen sich dann erst aber das ist jetzt eine google
geschichte ein blick hinter die kulissen der google suchen und schüss kann man system
2 android apps ist noch nicht drauf gibt es gibt es noch nicht aber faks oh ja endlich
zum glück ist das noch drauf hui nochmal nochmal gerettet unser gesundheitsamt hier
nochmal gerade gerade nochmal gerade nochmal gut gegangen windows faks und scan ist immer
noch drauf wieso sollte man android apps unter windows wollen frag mal microsoft die haben
android emulator jetzt dabei ich kann ich kann mir aber auch ein paar sinnvolle anwendungsgebiete
vorstellen zum beispiel wenn du eine notizen app hast unter android die kein windows gegenstück
hat und du benutzt irgendwie den eingebauten sing service oder irgendwas was halt nicht
so ohne weiteres sich sünden lässt windows notizen zum beispiel tiktok gucken es gibt
natürlich gibt es android emulator emulator ist aber wenn das standardmäßig dabei ist
ist natürlich ein bisschen mehr vertrauenswürdiger als das von den trittanbieter seite runterzuladen
und microsoft ist ja bekannt dafür dass ihre anwendung sonderbehandlung bekommen vielleicht
funktioniert ja einfach besser endlich instagram genau übrigens habt ihr auf twitter gesehen
ich habe aber das beste beste nummern schild gesehen irgendjemand aus leipzig so muss das
sein lull achtung überlänge lull jetzt ist die frage lacht er die anderen leute aus weil
er überlänge hat oder ist es eher lull in form von g-bait also nach dem motto achtung
überlänge lull dabei ist es gar nicht länger man wird es nie verstehen ich gut realistisch
betrachtet keines von beiden weil der absolut keine ahnung hat was wir unter lull verstehen
du hast heute das kennzeichen f-u-k-t gesehen ist auch nicht schlecht er lullt über die
eigene überlänge ja so würde ich das auch interpretieren war lull nicht in irgendeiner
sprache penis keine ahnung ist es das ich weiß nur was ich weiß nur was schwanz auf
türkisch heißt das weiß ich auch nur weil ich mit dem friseur lang genug einmal ausgespielt
habe ansonsten ist nicht was ihr denkt dass das haben wir erfahren weil er seine seine
characters in game etwas unglücklich benannt hat ohne es zu wissen bis uns dann irgendjemand
einer erzählte dass der schwanz auf türkisch heißt hast du noch kontakt so willi pete karst
nie lange schon nicht mehr also wenn man aus offenbach oder frankfurt kommt weiß man das
standardmäßig ich glaube das weiß heute halb deutschland was schwanz auf türkisch
heißt es gibt so ein paar wörter die setzen sich mit der zeit durch was eine sache die
mehr also ich habe ja überhaupt nichts gegen jugendsprache oder so einzuwenden ich mein
dass ich mit 37 vom rechner vom rechner sitzt und keck weh sage real life ist ja schon ist
ja schon bescheuert also ich ich bin der letzte da dass ich irgendwie drüber drüber beschwerden
hat aber was mir was mich heute übelst nervt ist dass ich dass das alle irgendwie mit bruder
anfangen und sowas es ist nicht jeder mein bruder mit der das finde ich total bescheuert
digga digga wobei ich muss sagen das geht sogar digga digga verwende ich nicht aber
das finde ich in ordnung ich bin ja noch aus der generation wo man gesagt hat alter alter
alda alda wie immer gesagt alda heute sagt man halt digga hovala genau ansonsten muss
man ja sagen diese diese diese wauts jugendwörter des jahres und so die hälfte dieser wörter
verwendet kaum einer also sagen die leute in dem alter selbst das schwach sind verwendet
keiner amis mögen digga nicht das stimmt das hat zu zu ja zu zu es hat zu ähnlichkeit
zu einem anderen wort dass dort nichts ja sehr hoch im kurs steht da muss man eh vorsichtig
auf flitsch das ganz ehrlich das hat er heute sein nächstes mal verloren ich verwende alter
im sinne von wtf ja ich auch ich verwende alter im sinne von wtf und im sinne von füllwörtern
ich habe letztens mal wieder von mir paar ältere videos geguckt und mir ist aufgefallen dass
ich seit anfang fast seit fast anfang an so eine rede wendung die verwende ich die verwende
ich in echt aber auch gerne habe da müsst ihr mal da müsst ihr mal müsst ihr mal drauf
achten und zwar wenn ich überlegen muss in videos was ich als nächstes sage dann sage
ich oft die dann habe ich so oft die rede wendung so bla bla bla und natürlich muss
man auch noch dazu sagen dass das sage ich total oft das sage ich immer wenn ich keine
ahnung habe was ich gerade sagen wollte müsst ihr mal drauf achten falls jemand die videos
auf youtube guckt immer wenn ich eine überleitung brauche und mir gerade nichts anderes einfällt
dann sage ich dann und man muss dazu sagen muss man auch noch das ja yep yep cock so ist
denn der frasier oder irgendeiner on no ich habe gehört da fabian hat bdo schon durchgespielt
jetzt meine youtube stimme ist anders ja gut das liegt das liegt daran weil ich das mikrofon
anders eingestellt habe hier habe ich hier habe ich das headset mikro statt das große
und ein bisschen raus unterdrückung ja erstellen mal bitte einen neuen order nene das mache
ich nicht sonst habe ich hier gleich die heckermans auf der vm wie findest du windows 11 naja ich
sehe immer noch die daseinsberechtigung nicht um ehrlich zu sein also warum man windows
11 wirklich jetzt braucht was man hätte nicht auch als ich meine jetzt aus microsofts sicht
war wenn ich halt hätte auch mit windows 10 machen können an patches aber wie gesagt
ich denke nach wie vor das ist ein taktisches release warum ausgerechnet jetzt keine ahnung
was sagst du zur nintendo switch ullert ja ist ok nachdem wir viele leute den kram auch
mobil verwenden umso besser das display umso umso nicer ja für mich kein kaufgrund also
püsse ich jetzt nicht weshalb aber kann man machen
so ein alex ich glaube umgedreht eher dass die das neue design nur gemacht haben um für
die nubs einen offiziellen grund zu haben für windows 11 weil die meisten leute wenn
man mal ehrlich sind haben doch gar keine ahnung was genau passiert also die interessieren
sich da auch nicht dafür die sehen oh gui hat sich geändert das muss neues betriebssystem
sein glaube die gui ist erst entstanden nachdem sie sich dafür entschieden haben windows 11
zu machen und nicht so nach dem motto wir wollen neues gui machen aber das man windows
11 macht auf zwei umgedreht ich hoffe nur dass man ordentlich updaten kann von 10 von
10 auf 11 nach möglichkeit ohne so eine interne neuinstallation die bei manchen windows updates
kommt weil dann muss ich meine festplatte wieder entschlüsseln dass es funktioniert
habe ich keinen bock drauf es dauert immer zwei stunden
ich werde auch erstmal nicht updaten ich sehe absolut kein grund aktuell ich werde
wahrscheinlich nach so eins zwei jahren dann updaten letzt mal chrome als standard browser
zack och du scheiß whatev monkaS was zum moment das ist die falsche das ist die falsches
falsche menü was da aufgeht oder was ich habe keine ahnung was ttp haben wir das vielleicht
so mal switch anywhere ok vielleicht vielleicht geht es jetzt was geht es jetzt damit ok das
war aber hardcore umständlich jetzt cool macht bitte auf jeden fall da ja ich habe es gerade
schon im chat gesehen aber ich mache ich nicht weil ich muss jetzt auf aber das ist echt
unnötig umständlich ob man mal ob das jetzt damit auch startet ja wieso ist ein windows
auf englisch ja weil ich englisch installiert habe ganz einfach betke leute betke betke
kommt jetzt betke time
massive betke ok leute wir sehen uns bis denn vielleicht programmieren wir morgen weiter
ok ich gehe jetzt auf bis denn see you nächste mal nächste mal gute nachtmusik see you